foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
ation bracket three Titans of the Chess
World will battle it out will it be the
genius of Magnus Carlsen or the Wizardry
of LA bonaronian or will it be the brute
force of Hikaru Nakamura only one will
enter the Grand Final we West James
James what on Earth I'm playing chess
right now what are you guys doing same
stuff we gotta go hold up hold up
checkmate
[Music]
how on Earth have we save this position
well Magnus just widening his eyes
they're shocked by this last decision
he's showing no fear whatsoever
he's throwing his throttle into the
white side holding on here for dear life
you see the bar go back to equal oh my
gosh it is beautiful tactile awareness
it's over we have a winner
we've had fantastic chess and so much
fun at the festival Masters today the
players will be on their game and we'll
make sure you don't miss any of the
action in the studio calling it out
Grandmaster David Howell peer Master
James Canty let's go and Grandmaster
Robert Hess
Magnus Carlsen love on our onion hey
karunakamura are in the elimination
bracket
something the chatsworld is used to how
bizarre is that David it's strange this
is worthy of being a final in fact it
was the final last time Hikaru Nakamura
and Magnus Carlson levonaroni in the mix
too but so many surprises especially
yesterday Tanya
so many big moments we had heartbreaks
and celebration
that one move self-made by Hikaru I'm
still getting over it James have you
seen anything like that by Hikaru
absolutely not and the internet is still
blowing up about it I mean it's crazy I
made it in one I mean it's on the board
everywhere right of course everybody's
seen it it was absolutely crazy of
course then you got Magnus Carlson
saying hey I'm not even I don't know
what a loser's bracket is basically he
was like I've never been here before
it's just so much craziness going on in
these matches yeah and we love it we
love it when the chess players do
Express these emotions we don't see that
often and yesterday we had a whole lot
of that how special is that Robert it's
amazing because chess historically is
played in silence it's studied in
silence now we see players duke it out
over the internet and then when they win
their game you see the fist pumps when
they lose their games checkmated one
they're shocked and you see it on their
face yeah
heartbreaks and celebration big moments
in day three take a look
these are the correct times does but
have enough time to win or Draw this
game
it's completely winning it's what they
call the Lucina position blacks porn
will make a new Queen
look at him
something oh my God why am I getting it
was a draw by repetition they repeated
it just in time because Lavon was
actually down on the clock at the end of
the game but he makes a draw there and
what a save
has Fabi just won a porn for free oh
Curry stepped back he's lost two moves
the queen just came from the square
Fabby says okay I'll go back and I've
nabbed a porn for free
which way do you go with the white king
so brave nerves are still oh my goodness
no no he made a movement it's coming in
bunches don't worry buddy when these
moves are happening they come in quickly
and then the clock will catch up oh my
goodness where's that King doing in The
Bishop's line of fire that's a
resignation that's it he resigns
he refuses repetition he says game on
and is taking big risk kill but what's
happening if you just Shuffle across
look you're pinned along the a file and
you're pinned on this diagonal oh wait
you're right about that whoa Fabiano
brilliant because the pawn A4 has it's
stranded it's gone too far Fabiano
cannot lose this game he's a pull-up ten
seconds David yeah two points up wow but
a horrible Bond structure yeah but it's
all about the white Deport if he kicks
the central point of life
oh my oh you said they don't blunder
Checkmate in one and a car immediately
does you commentator's cars
it is going to cost Hikaru the whole
match
wow a lot of excitement and drama there
and this is on the menu for the day how
much risk are the players willing to
take on day four of the adjustable
Masters we see there in our losers
semi-final this will be our first
matchup with Magnus Carlsen taking on
Levon aronian and on the other side of
that matchup is Hikaru Nakamura waiting
for the winner to take him on in the
losers final one player who's taking it
easy he's chilling today is Fabiano
caruana James how much of an advantage
is it for Fabi to get this rest in
before the Grand Final I think it's a
huge Advantage for fobby I mean Fabi is
able to rest his mind and his body as he
was trying to rest you know even lifting
weights lately right so a little bit of
rest there is always good he gets to
watch the games check everything see
what they're playing maybe some
armageddon's maybe some things go
through his brain but of course that
mental rest is very important because it
starts in the mental it starts right in
the mind yeah
so important to get that rest in but one
player who's got no time to rest because
he's been in the elimination bracket
since day one after losing to vladislav
our time you have is world champion
Magnus Carlsen and he is the reigning
Champions chest star champion he's of
course been on fire after losing that
game one he did mention that his match
against Wesley yesterday was the best
day that he's had on the tour so far I
still feel that he is he hasn't shown
his best yet David what do you think
about his play so far yeah first of all
what a CV that is uh but you're right
Tanya he didn't start at his best
especially day one losing to auntiev it
feels like he's needed time to warm up
but he is moving through the gears now
Magnus getting better day by day and
that's a scary Prospect for level
neronian it certainly is dangerous for
Lavon because if Magnus Carlson has not
been at his Peak and yet he dismantled
Wesley so yesterday I feel for Lavon
it's going to be a scary day for him
absolutely it's gonna be very piggyback
on the right he's it's gonna be scary
because Magnus the first day that was
just a Magnus we've never seen before
like Magnus what are you doing right
then of course he comes and just
destroys Wesley while he's eating
nonchalantly doing his laundry in the
back right still beating Wesley right
and now today if he's even stronger it's
gonna be a problem for LeBron aronian
but aronian I sure got something up his
sleeve for today yeah well the 15 time
world champion will be 15. what kind of
a number is that that's absolutely
insane but he it has got his stuff cut
up as he is facing another stalwood he
will be playing against Levon aronian
and what a fighter one of the most
creative players of the modern
generation he is a former World Cup
winner Robert what will it take for
Levon to get by today well Levon Aurora
is a history maker he has won the World
Cup twice the only player to do so he's
the fourth highest rated Peak rating in
history he's won the Olympia at three
times for a minute we couldn't list all
of his accomplishments on this brief
graphic so for Lavon he is a maestro he
loves the flare of the game and he's
taking down mags many times before he
can do it again today yeah in fact
Magnus is on record he said in
interviews in the past nobody has
outplayed him more in chess than level
neronian so he is capable levon's been
there beating him but he needs to bring
his a game today yeah two things right
LeBron Ronnie is what I like to call him
of course because you never know and you
know LeBron James and basketball I mean
you got LeBron aronian in chess the man
is an absolute Beast the second thing is
four digits two eight three zero 28-30
one of the very few on the planet to
reach 2 800 so if he's able to tap into
some of that ELO that he was able to
achieve before it could be a problem for
Magnus yeah
yeah only 40
am have crossed the 2800 Mark Lavon
aronen is one of them this is just how
strong the Champions chest door is
featuring the very best players in the
world we are in the second leg off the
tour this is how it works
the 2023 Champions chess tour is the
biggest tour yet with a thrilling brand
new format and two million dollars in
prizes it's the richest online
tournament of all time
the tour begins with six elite events
taking place between February and
September
each event features an open
qualification system with qualifiers and
plans locking in 56 players to the main
events
there players are grouped into three
divisions and compete for 235 thousand
dollars in prizes each time
victory in division one in any of the
six events secures a spot directly to
the eight player Champions chess tour
playoffs in December
players will also accumulate toward
leaderboard points across the six events
competing for another one hundred
thousand dollars in prize money and the
unsecured playoff spots will go directly
to the top leaderboard finishers at the
end of the year we have two weeks of
incredible chess beginning with the
playoffs for which just four players
will advance to the Champions chess tour
finals to a single elimination bracket
which will ultimately determine our
champion
together the playoffs and finals feature
a whopping 500 thousand dollars in
prizes
there could only be one
in December of 2023 an Undisputed tour
Champion will be crowned
let the games begin
235 000 accessible Masters is heating up
with division one but also division two
we do have the winners final today with
nordeback Abdu satro of taking on a
Maxine washer we see a big lead there
Robert between the two of them and in
the losers quarterfinal right now
kramnik against you Yankee yeah the
losers quarterfinal has Anish Geary he
is sluggling out with Dennis lazwick and
of course krumnik and yugany but
krumnick you know he went down loses
bracket after a pretty interesting day
yesterday yeah there was a lot of action
on the board but a lot of drama of it
what happened there yeah it was really
unfortunate honestly because early
stages of that match MBL he was up a
game game two krumbnic was on the verge
of a winning Advantage he Mouse slip and
dropped his Queen then in game three mvl
said here's giveaway you take the point
you deserve it after that debacle in
game two and then in game four all Max
Team needed was a draw unfortunate for
him in an equal position in an end game
his connection went out the window he
lost instead of going to Armageddon we
saw the players agree that MBL should go
on based on all the off the board
debacle
so much happening there and then after
all that settled down we did hear from
Maxine Bashar lagrav on Twitter this is
what he had to say it's been a very
frustrating day as this was not how I
wanted to win the match and had hoped
for a full fight at the chess board I
hope that from now on all the action
will only happen over the chessboard and
I would like to thank Vladimir kramnik
for his great sportsmanship and chesscom
for their reactivity in addressing this
issue some classy sportsmanship there
but David how frustrating is that for
the players uh frustrating it's the word
as Maxim used there I'm sure he wanted
to enjoy the moment he wanted to relish
the challenge of playing a great
Champion like Vladimir kramnik but this
is part of parcel part and parcel of uh
online chess and in the end it was a
nice Touch of Class from both players as
we saw the great sportsmanship leading
by example absolutely class and
sportsmanship are the worst sir it's a
competition and it's this is this is
like the future of chess the online
chess competitions things like this do
happen with the disconnections and of
course let me just let's hang in Queens
mouth slipping things like that it hurts
that that happens but it is part of it
and the good thing is that they were you
know came to agreement there great
sportsmanship and at the end of the day
people were able to pass through and you
know even though he lost um that was uh
chronic losing no problem there of
course hopefully good karma comes to him
and then he can make it through and at
the end of the day so there you go
so they know it there and we also have
action on in division three where there
are tour points as well as of course
prize money at stake and the Grand Final
will be between I'm in tabatabai and
Alexi Serrano Alexis Serrano we saw him
in division one of the Athens Masters
this is just a testament of how strong
chessable Masters is and what we are
looking for are some strong selfies from
all of you watching us don't forget to
send them with the hashtag chess Champs
you can't tag us on Instagram and there
is a grand prize of the new Air things
wave plus device so you will be winning
one of them and we will reveal the
winner at the end of the show I love it
very Sleek stuff here don't forget to
send us your selfies we'll also be
featuring some of them on our show but
right now the show is about this big
match that is coming up with Magnus
Carlsen taking on Levon aronian they
have played each other a bunch of time
times I can't even do the math that is a
lot of games but 32 wins to Magnus James
what do you think about that score line
the score line looks great for Magnus
but also I mean it's just hey LeBron
aronian for a reason that's 21 wins it
looked like the Wesley thing now of
course what happened there is like oh
Wesley hit him Wesley was swinging big
flexley so and then he got flexed on
real fast by Magnus there so yeah The
Score says a lot but he's definitely
gonna have to prove this these 21 wins
today and I
in style actually suits this kind of
match well it's only two games variance
is how
for Lavon he oh swings he's always
playing Fighting Chess I think he can
take Magnus down in this format yeah we
saw in the graphic over a hundred games
against each other just in Rapid that is
incredible They Know Each Other's
strengths They Know Each Other's
weaknesses and uh it'll be fascinating
to see how they both try and pinpoint
those during this match
yeah it is going to be about keeping
your nerves in control when we will have
times
moment these are the regulations of the
loser's bracket they will be playing a
best of two match so the first player to
get one and a half points wins the match
they will have 15 minutes on the clock
with a three second increment in case of
a tie we will see the bidding Armageddon
but before that it is a best to do the
clocks are ticking which means we are
about to lift off what Robert are you
expecting in the openings here oh that's
a good question from levonne veroni
typically a D4 player but in recent
years he's playing one E4 and he's
always touted to be a player who plays
D4 like he's playing E4 so he likes to
mix it up yeah and Magnus had some
really nice opening surprises that are
going for this aggressive Pawn
sacrifices against Wesley are we
expecting that kind of dynamic play from
him with the white pieces today I think
he's going to try to keep it more calm
and quiet you know that's what Magnus
likes to do he doesn't look for big
opening advantages he likes some small
squeezes of course and aronian is
creative he likes the Titans he likes
the aggression the powerful chest right
the creativity here yeah C4 right I mean
it could be tactical but of course I
mean it could also be very slow here
kind of English yeah it's the English
opening uh this is something that Magnus
has used on occasion Levon famous for
using this himself as white as well and
okay the Four Knights variation all the
night's coming out very early and Magnus
opens up the center and Magnus there
with the food Gambit as well we see him
that's worked out really well in the
past it's a great opening yeah it's
worked for him why not do it again and
Lavon pausing at this early stage and
not munching on the white porn in the
center he's uh bypassed that kicking
away the White Knight I've got to admit
I've played the opening the English my
whole life and I've never seen this
position already uh wow the players
surprising each other surprising us what
could the idea be here will we see a
bunch of exchanges in the center no
Levon just brings his Bishop out Speedy
development uh from Levon there and
already wrecking the white structure
doubled pawns about to happen on the
board for white and
early days but I quite like this
position for Lavon I've got to say yeah
so do I because right now white has
those double pawns and I feel like in
speed chess in quicker time controls
it's just more difficult to have these
double pawns because they can get
attacked and are difficult to defend so
I feel like for Lavon he's happy with
how the opening has gone but that pawn
on e4 the pawn that was in front of his
King it's a bit too far it could get
stranded and white can attack it yeah
that plug that pawn sorry it's uh
definitely the Target and Magnus to see
him play Such provocative chess allowing
these doubled pawns to retreat his
knight uh to kind of allow black to
advance like this it must be preparation
um Magnus must have done his homework
here yeah definitely I'm just wondering
how does he have more time than what he
started with while eating
that's true of course I mean he also
understands positions Pawn structures I
mean he understands everything five-time
World Champ right so in 15 titles it's
insane right so I mean he can do really
any G4 oh my goodness there we go
we don't know Magnus that's exactly what
I'm talking about big fella that's how
we do things around here yes sir for the
score man he got you to jump off the
camera absolutely
anytime I can play G4 4 or H4 in a game
I'm already hey look at LeBron he like
this like bro what the heck just
happened not expecting that move from
anybody oh my goodness I'm already I
can't wait to see how this one pans out
T4 can we explain it I mean can you guys
explain this though for the people
watching right now why am I so hype
about G4 go on take it away Robert has
Magnus morphed into Shakira mamajarov
you know it does feel like that right we
see a position where white is throwing
pawns at the board the king is still in
the center that may seem dangerous but
black doesn't have peace in the attack
and I was pointing out that the pawn on
e4 can become vulnerable you see that
Knight the only piece defending it white
may push the pawn up to G5 kicking the
night out of there to win the pawn not
to mention that black tries to stop G5
with move H6 that creates a hook in the
position so white could push the button
to H4 and then when G5 is played next
you are opening up the king Side by
force that is bad news for the black
king so sometimes I know your coaches
tell you you should always Castle early
sometimes castling early can backfire if
the position opens up on that flank not
to mention just one more thing that the
white Bishop can slide into G2 to put
maximum pressure on the E4 Pawn yeah it
looks like everything's going in White's
favor here on less level and Ronin can
somehow mix things
it's really hard to go for the white
king this is why Magnus can get away
with such early uh kind of naked
aggression here just throwing pawns
forward because the white King Super
safe in the center it's locked in the
middle of the board so this white king
is feeling pretty comfy right now you
could imagine actually it castling on
the other flank opposite side castling
and big attacks either way but this is
the big threat left on Iranian it's not
easy for him to guard against it for
example a move you would want to play is
to bring the Rook across just to guard
this point in the center that Robert's
mentioning but look at this the Knight
trapped nowhere to go and already after
a few moves Levon arunian on the back
foot okay after a bit of a think there
he does push his Pawn but questions to
answer he's basically going a pawn down
on the next turn he has to move his
Knight away it's gonna Retreat somewhere
and uh after Magnus takes support Levon
needs compensation
urgently otherwise he's just gonna lose
this game
move the Knight to D7 I mean just take
the pawn I don't know what is he gonna
play after that what are you gonna play
after I take this free pawn put the
bishop on D3 oh my goodness my tactic
senses are tingling like you know Spidey
senses these tactic senses right now
Knight takes C4 there it is Bishop to D3
Queen H5 and get him off the board he
had to play F5 I knew that was coming
though okay F5 what what does F5 do here
David I guess uh he's just trying to
open lines if the white knight Retreats
now then Black's Queen is able to come
out on the diagonal and grab a Pawn on
G5 but if Magnus captures this Pawn on
pass on as if it just moved one square
so the white Pawn would capture on the
F6 Square things open up blacks pieces
will come to life and if we do a quick
count we see that white has only really
developed one piece the white knight in
the center whereas black is already
castled black will have some open lines
the Black Knights are out so uh yes
white is one point up but black is
slightly quicker with and slightly more
active with his pieces so does it
balance out I'm not sure I'm
materialistic but uh what do we think
Robert Chad is confused is amperson
forced
that's a different game okay but I
actually think
you think is the likeliest move it's
just very very dangerous because if you
take this Pawn on passant as Magus just
did then black will take back with the
Knight and lines are opening up I keep
saying this when you drop a pawn maybe
it's a blunder the good news is you've
opened files for your Rooks and here at
the black Rook on f8 the queen will join
the party the white king is sitting in
the center it's not very pretty you have
not developed your pieces and Magnus
moved his Knight back to G3 so he's
moving the same piece multiple times
he's lacking in development the eval bar
approves but perhaps the vonaronian
likes the initiative here yeah there are
already ideas on tap for example
bringing the bishop out hitting the
White Queen trying to get control over
the light squares you can make an
argument for jumping forward with the
Black Knight again attacking this Pawn
trying to get the black queen out to a
nice active Square white will have
replies to this white is still
relatively solid but there are certainly
attacking ideas available to live on and
we all know he's a dynamic player
positional strategic considerations out
the window he is going to go for the
white king that's the only way to
justify the fact he's a pawn down long
term white has the two Bishops and white
has that extra Central Pawn so uh Levon
knows it's here and now that he needs to
strike back and he does that by
shuffling his Queen across lining her up
with the white king early days but uh
who would you pick here James
I'm going to pick white here Tanya what
about you
oh I was hoping you wouldn't ask me that
question to me it's just amazing that
Magnus Thoughts with the English opening
then just G4 sacrifices upon for the
initiative Levon picking that up and and
now this kind of a position I don't
really see a Checkmate or a tactical
blow immediately of course but it feels
like a long-term compensation for black
the files are open white still hasn't
castled Fields behind in development the
bishop once it comes out to G4 I was
just about to say which has been stopped
Magnus making too many pawn moves I'm
going to pick black here I love the
compensation and the initiative in this
format I think it's harder to defend
than it is to uh play with just being a
pawn up yeah usually you do burn a lot
more time defending trying to look for
those resources but Magnus he's still
playing really really quickly and this
last move it's not intuitive it's not a
natural one yes you guard some squares
but look how loose the white structure
is right right now look at the white
king and uh Magnus must be feeling very
very confident to play a move such as
this one yeah that was actually pretty
ugly move I'm not gonna lie being fine
go says never play F3 or F6 shout out to
find gold of course F3 and F6 first off
fine go is tripping after that move
secondly right uh here I actually feel
like white here believe it or not I am a
fan of the dynamic chess so I'm going to
Castle Queen side believe it or not I'm
going to put the bishop on D3 maybe go
Queen C2 right all the pieces are gonna
aim at the king side I want to put a
rook on G1 they'll come on Magnus
I'm a Jedi some people forget that
sometimes Rook to G1 Bishop D3 Queen to
C2 right I'm gonna put the key or Bishop
maybe on D2 Castle Queen side and go for
everything hence the move Knight A5 I do
like this move from aronia he's like
yeah you probably want to get your king
over there he understands he's
aggressive and creative himself so he
kind of understands some of these ideas
he just puts a knight on A5 and say
maybe at some point I can get my pieces
over why he played E4 whoa in the middle
of the board he just doesn't care about
nothing today what is this Robert what's
wrong with him you know he's Brave
that's what Magnus Carlson is and I'm
wondering if he's actually studied this
position before his Rook on G1 is
staring down at the black king that's
the good news for Magnus the problem for
him is his own kings in the center but
he's shielding his King with essentially
a wall of Pawns it's a moat just like if
you Castle you Pawns in front of your
king these pawns happen to be on the
fourth ring the bad news about having
extended pawns against is that they're
easier to attack a bishop for black can
go to A6 or to E6 attack that pawn on C4
that's sticking out and doubled so I
feel like LaVon will have his counter
play but first he tries to take care of
his King King to h8 I think is a smart
prudent move and he will then go after
the material
yeah I love it because that Rook Rook
moved to G1 putting it on the G file
also stops Lavon from bringing his own
Bishop onto the fan chatter diagonal
because you need to make sure that
White's Knight doesn't jump into the
attack forward all the way to F5 so I
like that move because it allows Black's
Rook to step up onto the defense nicely
play it there freeing up the pieces I
just think a Magnus he's playing fast
but he's made so many pawn moves this is
going to be a very dangerous position
for white I'm still picking black here
guys
yeah the white piece is still asleep
other than the knights maybe which woke
up a long long time ago but the rest
need that wake-up call and uh I think
it's time for Magnus as James mentioned
start developing those Bishops I'm not
sure which one first but bring one of
the Bishops out to the center that white
king really needs to get off the same
line as that black queen uh all of these
considerations but time is the issue do
you have time for all of them Levon will
strike soon and he'll strike hard and
fast this actually reminds you of a
nimso Indian the A3 that's at the
same-ish variation an A3 F3 something
like that but it's a one of the
variations where you actually put the
Knight on A5 for black here you play
Bishop A6 and the queen is actually
nicely placed in fact Roman DZ slapped
the keyboard my guy he actually does
things uh he has a very nice um system
for black here where he puts the bishop
on A6 and you also bring the queen in
fact it's already ideally placed usually
the queen would be on d8 but actually
because it's on E8 you would actually
put the queen on C6 to attack this C4
Pawn it's doubled so Bishop A6 this is
why the knights on a 5 to attack the
weak Pawn on C4 Bishop A6 and queen C6
or F7 will attack this C4 pawn and try
to bully it and win it many times you
actually are able to win this Pawn it's
only one piece defending it now the
bishop on D3 you go Queen E2 that's the
second piece defending but three pieces
attacking that pawn is going to be a
problem for Magnus so he needs to
actually move very quickly here and
figure out what to do Bishop A6 is on
top we move the queen and then I guess
after he defend or attacks the pawn on
C4 with Queen C6 or F7 we may have a D5
there which is overextending our pawns
slightly here I still like white here
but black definitely has some serious
counter play yeah I like those ideas
James and I think Levon will choose uh
either bring the black queen out or
bring his Bishop out now just pick maybe
picking the order worrying about uh if
there are any consequences behind his
moves but uh yeah already Magnus
slightly ahead on the clock I did fear
that uh Levon aronian might get in time
trouble recently he's been playing a bit
slower this tournament especially maybe
not at his quickest not at his best but
uh yeah that might come to pass
yeah I'm so surprised looking at this
position I'm just wondering if Magnus is
more distracted with the food than he
should be because this is insane I mean
if we didn't tell anyone who are the two
players playing here and played a little
guess the ELO game Robert just with the
king in the center the pawns Advanced no
development
it's the only good thing for white is
that it's Magnus playing white and now
night's in the rim so lavon's joining
the party right he's you're eating leave
some leftovers for me I want that cake
too and he's putting both of his Knights
on the rim so they're Breaking All the
principles your coaches teach you so uh
listen to your coaches everybody do as
they say none of these players do
they're so high level they can do this
thing but it makes sense here because
the Rook on f8 for black after castling
is on an open file the Knight moves out
the way there are some vulnerable
squares in the position that night May
jump into F4 forcing the dark Square
Bishop off the board remember white is
up a pawn so where is Black's
compensation going to come from it's
going to come from the fact that Black's
King is tucked in the corner probably a
little bit safer and white will have
these weak pawns as James is pointing
out the C4 Pawn in particular it sticks
out like a sore thumb black can team up
on it but lavon's first taking care of
that dark Square Bishop he does not want
to see that one come into the attack
yeah uh why not jump in force that
Bishop off the board as Robert says and
actually two Targets uh as both of you
are mentioning this one but uh so this
F3 Pawn a bit of a backward Pawn black
could certainly line up actually on this
Square uh teaming up against this Target
and potentially on this target with the
black queen so okay this has happened uh
this was very logical play by both sides
white Bishop pair Advantage is gone so
it's now it's just purely about material
and levonaroni he won't be too worried
actually about the structure black has
access to squares especially this Black
Brook sitting nice and pretty now on F4
yeah and what material those are two
double pawns on the C file James has
been pointing out that it's going to be
under Fire I don't really see it what I
don't understand is that why does our
eval bar still like White's position so
much lack of development bad Pawn
structure also just one extra point is
that in our photo is our silicon friend
being a little deceptive here
don't know I tend to trust the computers
in messy or strange positions like this
often computers get it wrong when it's
really locked up really closed and
sometimes late in end games they do
overestimate one side's chances but here
I like magnus's last move gotta say
maybe black has to retreat his Rook I
don't know if there's any way to keep it
on this active Square that's the problem
right yeah you want to keep it there but
unfortunately for Lavon he's got to move
it back because otherwise his Rook may
be lost on the score you try to protect
it it gets blocked and then it gets won
by white so just for example Queen
episode Knight F5 is an example you cut
off the circulation between the queen
and the Rook here and that's a problem
because now all of a sudden white wins
material so if you had to retreat that's
not a good sign I like what Lavon has
been able to accomplish but I feel like
if you have to take a step back after
making sure that you're putting no
longer is the bishop pair it's not
entirely what LeBron wanted yeah look at
this structure I don't think Magnus will
play it now but you could build the four
Pawn wall and uh this is pretty scary
foreign interface so also James you
mentioned this idea earlier uh fortune
teller here cast in queenside finally it
is available in the next few moves if
you want to get your king to safety
absolutely I'm a big fan of casting
Queen side here and after I Castle I go
Rook to G2 and I double the Rooks and
then watch where you look you better be
very very careful here because I can
just move the Knight and it may be night
night for you so it's a very very very
uh scary position and an attacking type
of position the positions that we all
are fun and we love to play so it is
some problems for Lavon here but
definitely Magnus has to to tread
lightly C4 is definitely hanging I mean
sometimes you may have a queen A4 there
in many cases so you have to be careful
from White side too as well I'm curious
to see where he goes and he already
surprises here with F3 and like some
other both so let's see what Magnus
plays here yeah let's see what he plays
this is the type of moment where it
would be logical for Magnus to take
things because there are no obvious
options we've mentioned Castle in
queenside but uh James also highlighting
the fact that Queen can actually jump
towards that side of the board and I've
also mentioned kind of half jokingly
that white can step some pawns forward
in the center but that creates
weaknesses as well feels a bit loose
nowhere for the White Knight to jump
forward to right now so no logical
intuitive move that's when the top
players in the world sit on their hands
and have a deep think yeah I'm listening
to Oliver and I'm still confused do you
like white or black David definitely
white white James what about you
definitely white a thousand percent all
right I thought that that James was
gonna say black because you know so
everything you're saying you're
highlighting a potential attack things
of that nature but I'm gonna have to go
with them because I think that white has
a really cool move here that oftentimes
we're thinking purely in terms of attack
but I do think that white may take a
step back before going forward this
Knight on G3 it's not the best place
piece in the world it can't jump forward
maybe it should go back to F1 and then
reroute to D2 where it protects both of
White's weaknesses at the same time we
keep highlighting and that's the only
reason I thought about it is that the C4
Pawn the F3 Pawn those are our targets
black Sun God for them that Knight on D2
protects them both that's fancy it's not
just the soup
get that get that man on camera fancy
80. wow fancy in the suit Fancy on the
board Fancy with the moves Knight F1 is
a fancy move I actually like that
reroute yeah it's a phantom
it's a really difficult one to find
because we all know that
know that eating moves are
as radar James Knight F1 I also like
this E5 move E5 is very committal but my
idea here is to actually just play Queen
E4 there and actually Hit The Rook nh7
at the same time E5 is a really
committal move but if it works I mean
there's definitely some potential here
I'm opening up the bishop line I also
can play Knight at five it's something
I'm trying to do for instance if a
bishop beats up C5 something five okay
yeah he was thinking it that's a crazy
move though that's a wild move engine
improves but it's definitely a wild move
what if he just takes the pawn yeah I
think Magnus knows that porn was going
to be a long-term weakness anyway and
rather than uh kind of hamstring himself
rather than saddle himself with a
long-term weakness he's happy to give
the pawn back and now it will be black
with doubled pawns if he captures uh
I've got to say I'm surprised as well
was not on my radar at all I was looking
at some ways to protect things as well
but uh Magnus stepping forward showing
the mood he's in he's in an aggressive
mood Magnus he's throwing all of his
pawns forward at every given opportunity
and uh you're right Chase what's the
first what's the reply if black just
snaps that one off especially the b-pawn
bc5 it opens up the B file now casting
Queen side you're gonna have to watch or
I mean you're about to block with your
whole face if you Castle Queen sorry
Rook B8 I mean you might get made it you
know real quick so that's very scary so
I'm not sure what he has in mind after
bc5 which is now on the board yeah
strange to play C5 your opponent kind of
takes the point you've just offered and
then start to think
yeah pretty strange he recaptures but
now ugly pawns again and I really don't
like the fact that he's given the black
queen access to some really nice squares
in the center which is immediately uh
utilized by Levon aronian suddenly
threats have appeared this point Under
Fire this Pawn Under Fire and Magnus is
he losing control it looks like it yeah
because when you have not castled your
king why are you opening up the position
your king is in the center I think that
this was a mistake from Magnus the
evaluation bar suggests that it's not so
bad for him he's still hanging right in
this game but I just don't like the
trajectory of the game at first magazine
to be the one in control he forced
and then he pushed his Pawn too soon
when his King remains in the center and
now he is backtracking with the Knight
and maybe Queen D4 next actually if he
could trade those Queens off the board
he will be better he is up a pawn well
then it might be time for black to
actually recapture that pawn with his
own Pawn taking away that Central Square
that you're talking about so that
there's no more Queen trade can Levon
level the material by recapturing on C5
level level
uh yes he can take this Pawn I guess
magnus's idea would now be that he has a
past Pawn of his own long term okay he
takes this Pawn with his Queen but long
term white does have a passer in the
center uh so for example you could start
gaining time hit the black queen and as
James actually mentioned earlier pushed
forward try to start attacking the black
king that's why Levon went for the queen
trade he was too scared of this
continuation and uh in this position he
simply took with his Queen instead and
now we see a structure like this one
black has these ugly doubled C pawns
white has a passer long term but uh can
white get his pieces organized I
wouldn't be surprised if Magnus actually
uses his King as an active Defender
there is a pawn under under Fire here
under threat so why not defend it with
your king and we're in the end game we
know who that favors in terms of
strengths and weaknesses Magnus and game
maestro
yeah the Magnus touch that we keep
hearing about Magnus Carlton is an
absolute beast when it comes to end
games but in this particular one Levon
looks like he's got his own trumps that
F3 weakness he can start targeting it
maybe reroute the Knight to the center
of the board Robert you highlighted it
Knight on the edge that A5 night not
liking it is that a piece James that
needs to come back in the action
absolutely of course from uh accessible
books I always like to give you guys
those right a Grandmaster preparation
positional play from Jacob Agar right
what is the worst place piece now of
course when you ask that it could be a
few of them but definitely the Knight on
A5 we would even work on A8 is pretty
rough too as well you haven't moved it
the bishop on C8 not really a terrible
piece that has options but the Knight
definitely not one that you need to
figure out where do you actually want to
put it it's offsides right now you also
have a weakness on C5 but at least the
Rook on f8 is active for black I do like
the idea of moving my king to F2 maybe
even moving it to E3 having a very
active King here as we approach an
in-game here and even I mean even Rook
G5 at some point is going to attack that
c Pawn so we have to figure out what we
want to do maybe we move the Knight to
B7 that's an interesting move it depends
upon because black actually is facing a
dilemma here with the C5 Pawn Rook G5 is
going to be quite annoying King F2 is on
the board yeah and we're facing a
dilemma became your selfies because
you're sending such great ones don't
forget to keep them coming we will be
revealing the winner of our selfie
contest use the hashtag chess Champs and
you could win this very cool new black
Air things device so keep those selfies
coming we will be featuring them on our
show yeah and I've got to say I'm really
surprised I like weights position I
think white has the better Pawn
structure but a few minutes ago we saw
stockfish the engine suggestions and it
gave white a plus two Advantage plus two
plus two that feels huge from where what
part was close to King F2 apparently
gives us a massive Advantage for white
and we see the evaluation bar heading up
so drastically and James you mentioned
some of the ideas for white Brewing the
white king to the center bring the white
Rook up on the G file maybe it's just a
combination of those uh long term black
struggling wow I'm surprised it's that
big I've got to save that Advantage but
black has nothing to attack that's part
of the problem here is that the one
weakness the king just protected this is
an end game use your king to your
advantage don't just hide it away like
you have to do with Queens on the board
the king will slink forward up to E3 it
will protect everything and at some
point white does have a clear pass Pawn
in the center and James pointed out a
great idea for white as well Rook to G5
hitting the pawn along the fifth Rank
and then you can double your Rooks in
the G file and launch an attack so white
actually has the safer King even though
it's more out in the open and I think
that black has a lot to deal with and
there we go Magnus uh puts that move on
the board he hits this weak Pawn
levonaronian reacts with a counter
threat hitting the loose white Bishop
but I'm expecting Magnus now to go for
that idea okay he doesn't bring his King
into the center he moves his Bishop out
the way uh so still this Pawn in the
firing line how can Lavon aronian get
some counter play the evaluation bar did
drop slightly so maybe this bishop not
that well placed uh on B5 for white
feels like it is a target black can kick
it away at some point with a pawn uh
maybe some counter play the white Rook
uh sorry not the white Rook the white
king now no longer covering an
infiltration by the BlackRock and uh
okay that's why I was skeptical
originally it didn't feel like that
dominant position for white it feels
like you can still lose control if
you're not careful and levonaroni will
try and work some kind of magic some
kind of uh chaos into this end game uh
it's not going to be as one-sided as the
earlier evaluation might suggest
practical chances I mean practical
chances meaning you know you're playing
a human here well Magnus feels like half
a human right but at the same time of
course these guys are extremely strong
here and he's creating threats him
meaning Magnus doing great things I mean
you can double the Rooks here King E3
definitely is looking good too as well I
mean what does uh aronian even do about
the C5 Pawn do we push past maybe play
C4 but then that opens up the D4 Square
for the knife here C5 is actually
hanging I did mention Knight B7 but
that's probably why he played Bishop B5
so you can go Bishop C6 or A6 now
um to attack this Knight and that that's
defending the pawn on C5 yeah it's
looking difficult love on aronian one
and a half minutes down on the clock as
well maybe we can bring back those
computer suggestions how can black
minimize the damage or how can black uh
at least ask some questions to Magnus
Carlson I don't really see his kind of
strong convincing move here I've got to
admit if the black Rook does come down
to the second rank the white King's
gonna kick it and wow only one move
keeps the advantage White's Advantage at
a manageable proportions Pawn to A6
Robert of course obvious yeah obviously
right now Asics is actually a wonderful
idea one that was not on any of our
Radars we all looked at each other here
like what but it makes perfect sense
once the engine suggests it because if
white is to take the pawn on A6 that
opens up a line for the black Rook The
Rook shifts back to its starting Square
on A8 the bishop moves back to B5 the
Knight comes into B3 taking advantage of
the fact that the pawn on A2 is pinned
because if you take the Knight you lose
your rook and that would not be good and
even there actually says that white is
still slightly better but if you move
your Rook away and instead of taking the
Knight then the black Rook infiltrates
and that Knight on B3 protects the C5
Pawn as well so there are tactics
everywhere the Knight can come into D2
to win the F3 Pawn yikes this is just a
crazy line yeah and not just the F3 Bond
the E4 Pawn will also be hanging here
because the F3 Pawn has been with forks
everywhere now A6 just giving up a pawn
to actually defend upon what a creative
idea but if there's one player who can
find it it is Levon arunin he is
thinking currently in the position he's
burnt I mean
oh my God
I think we know what the half everything
else is stop it stop this well you
better get him checked
it is on the board The Rook on the A5
this is fire is Magnus Carlsen going to
go into a think tank right now how
difficult is this for white I think the
shock value is enormous here Magnus will
not have had this on his radar when he
first brought his Bishop over to B5 and
just genius from level on Iranian yes
amazing creative active defense that's
the key and now you predicted that Black
Knight on the board hitting that white
rook in the corner black has counter
play the momentum is on black side
ignore the evaluation bar this one
anything can happen now and it's one of
the biggest compliments people give
levonne aronian is he is able to solve
technical tasks tactically and that's
what he just did his position looked bad
his structure was ugly these doubled
isolated Pawns of the C file and I say
eight points here take it I'm gonna
jettison that pawn to open up lines for
my pieces he wants the tactics to get
going he wants active play rather than
passive defense and right now The Rook
moves he could take this Pawn on A2
actually I'm not sure why the evaluation
bar is so heavily in White's favor Black
suddenly getting counter play but Magnus
seems unperturbed yeah just calmly
centralizing his King calmly
centralizing all of his pieces there's a
nice little diamond formation in the
center there with white spawns Bishop
Knight and uh the white king safest
houses in the middle of the board so
yeah this one maybe still favoring white
objectively but it needed Magnus to keep
that calm head a lesser mortal like me
would have been panicking I would have
seen levon's move I would have thought
oh my gosh I've blundered it's turned
around but uh Magnus keeping calm moving
quickly that's the more important factor
Levon down to one minute can he keep the
tricks coming can he keep finding those
Dynamic ideas to test Magnus well two
things here I think are the wrong with
with LeBron's position when is the time
okay the time you have to use it as a
piece here you can't be you can't beat
down that much time it's almost the same
thing with Hikaru you down a lot of time
on Hikaru it's not going to end well
right same thing with Magnus it usually
doesn't end well he's done a lot of time
here number two here is after he made
all of this play right A6 was great we
got to Rook to A2 now what right is the
problem it's like now what do I do the
Knight is kind of strange over here on
B3 I have no swears actually especially
after King E3 okay it is defending my C5
Pawn right but of course white still has
to pass Pawn I can now play F4 F5 get
these pawns rolling I can double the
Rooks and really my king bishop and
Knight aren't just chilling they're just
kind of chilling right there maybe you
could play C4 at some point as black
here pawns to C4 we back the bishop up
and attack The Rook right but we still I
mean we have Tim Tempe Rick to G1 we
still can play at four at five and it
feels like there there's something for
uh for white in every position so much
time there oh wow you have 15 seconds
what do you play H6 just a little move
on to King side attacking the Rogue but
love on our onion is down to 14 seconds
rookie five attacks the bishop falls
back things are getting tricky for black
not just on the board but the clock yeah
it feels like LaVon is actually the one
panicking here it's inconsistent to kind
of play Such active uh chess on one side
of the board then take a timeout with a
quiet move on the other flank but uh
yeah that three minute advantage that
might be even more decisive than White's
Advantage now uh it's a big pen that's a
big bin if you sidestep with the King
maybe he's thinking about an exchange
sacrifice on F7 and bring that Bishop on
the diagonal that could be brutal for
black so maybe that was an only move to
stop that Bishop C4 idea the time I was
talking about but this drops the pawn
that Knight was doing a very important
defensive task it goes back to the rim
we keep talking about how dim it is over
there and C6 now the Knight again is
saddled to the defensive upon white a
clean Pawn up now and with the advantage
11 not Magnus Levon shaking his head
there he's not happy with this that
Knight on A5 has been a big problem in
his position it continues to stay so and
now it is Magnus Carlsen who does have
the extra pawn and a lot of extra time
on the clock will Lavon be able to hold
this one
no no yeah it ain't looking good here
especially I mean you have to remove
like H4 how slow of that is I mean
that's just you got so many moves and he
just plays H4 stopping G5 that's tough I
mean you got a lot of things to think
about here I only have a few seconds
left he is literally about the flag too
okay he made that with three seconds two
seconds seconds on the clock oh trick
from left on aronian he throws in a
check if this Knight is captured by the
white Bishop Black's Rook is actually on
the third right gonna come and take a
pawn with track attacking multiple
pieces yeah Magnus I think must have
missed this trick Levon really
resourceful he played this move with two
seconds on his clock but the problem is
Magnus can just capture this Knight and
if we do a quick count at the very end
here after this bishop Retreat white has
a knight and Bishop for blacks Rook not
just that white Central Pawn is going to
start marching forward very shortly so
Knight and Bishop versus Rook is a small
material advantage but also there's two
versus one and uh that should be enough
to win this game for Magnus still some
work to be done there unfortunately
those pins we see a pin along the third
rank towards the white king and now
appearing along the D file towards all
of White's pieces but you can't maximize
it there's no pressure to continue
putting on these pieces white will step
out of the pin in the near future you
have to be careful as David was saying
but even pushing your Pawn forward at
this point seems to be a good way to
cause black enough problems and then you
continue marching that pawn forward
black will not be able to exert more
pressure and win a piece yep any time
the black porn steps forward to kick
away this white knight this white knight
will move move with tempo for example it
can kick away this black rook and land
itself now on a beautiful Square just uh
yeah blocking everything creating
threats of their own with night forks
and this one should be game over Magnus
just needs a few accurate moves this is
the current position we're all expecting
him here to step his Pawn forward no he
drops his Knight back instead but this
Pawn forward uh will come later uh yeah
Magnus just holding things all you need
to do is avoid any tricks against your
Bishop to do with these pins left on
shaking his head yet again
should be over soon yeah Magnus played
like a computer here I mean really
having a half machine for real here it
was just it felt like black had
something at one point but he really at
the end of the day really just didn't
have anything the night was very very
bad for majority of the game and then uh
we also got low on time which causes uh
lots of problems when you get along time
we got some counter play though yeah the
promise the White Knight has a beautiful
Square to sit on in the middle of the
board it can block the black Rook on the
D file and uh the black pawns very weak
unfortunately you only have two pieces
with black the two Rooks white has three
Bishop Knight and Rook when you're down
material that's the defense side you've
got to try and trade off bonds so Lavon
going for that part with G5 but it
doesn't look like the troubles are going
to stop here is Magnus going to take
this one because if he does that means
that he would need just a draw to clinch
the match and face Hikaru Levon will
play the next one with the white pieces
what are the chances of left saving this
one
zero percent there's just nothing there
I mean it's not on time what do you
think Robert zero is okay is high that's
a really high number I just don't miss
the C4 trick that levon's setting up
right now that is the one trick
available we're talking about a pin
along the third rank so if black can
push that pawn successfully then white
will lose this bishop however Magnus
plenty of time is clock even though he
is getting himself got a little bit
lower he blocks the pin now his Bishop
can move and once he solved all of his
problems he does have a pass Pawn as
David said he's three pieces just two
for black and oh he brings Knight
backwards he's doing that backwards to
go forwards might be what what a move
fast it's like you pointed out earlier
Robert that F1 move you mentioned
earlier backward night moves are the
hardest to see the trickiest to see but
the whole idea is he's going round the
long way he's rotating his Knight around
to blockade that black past Pawn there
we go now the Knights of the best
blockadas that black pawn is uh rendered
irrelevant pretty much and White's Rook
is finally free to go active itself just
beautiful strategic play yeah that was a
really nice maneuver there by the night
a bit of a master class there on how to
play these end games but that is the
Magnus Magnus touch and it seems like he
is on the way to Victory is it as simple
as just Advance with the king and the
epon yeah or deliver a Checkmate I mean
I wouldn't be surprised if the white
Rook goes up the board well now you can
trade Rooks that should be easy enough
for Max's why should I do that I'll go
after your weak pawn put black in a
defensive posture and it might be time
soon to push that e-pawn but first bring
the Knight into the game yep he's sport
for Choice here Magnus uh pretty much
anything wins at this point that white
Rook as well once it gets active once it
starts checking that black king it will
be game over uh simply mating attack I
think is the word and why not lead the
attack with a king the king leads from
the front here in an end game and uh
okay offering that trade of Rooks white
Central Pawn should guarantee the win
even with a set of Trades and here we go
all the pieces combining look how well
coordinated they the White Knight
protects the white Bishop the white king
is matching either side forward now the
white Pawn in the center just doing a
fantastic job black is stuck everything
defends each other for white and
beautiful you can see the frustration on
level of ronin's face he knows he's done
not that much wrong in this game yeah
but he's been powerless to avoid defeat
yeah it's almost hard to pinpoint the
moment when things went so wrong for
love and I'm just wondering if it was
that critical Queen trade while fighting
for initiative which is the point when
Magnus got the advantage and converted
it flawlessly to Victory Magnus taking
the first game in his mini-match against
Levon some that came up for us Robert
well Magnus he won a pawn in the opening
he played an ambitious line but pushing
his kingside pawns off the board without
castling and then he gave upon back at
the right time to get active play so he
said material will be equal the position
will not yeah that was a power pack
performance by the world champion in
game one and this is a scoreline Levon
aronian with the white pieces has to win
on demand to level the score and take it
to Armageddon we will be back with the
action but first for our non-subscriber
as we've got a twitch break
[Music]
welcome everybody my name is
Champion our starting a new course here
for chessable a very special chessful
course master your chest with Judith
Boulder you know what I
wow
[Music]
chess is an exercise in Awareness it is
evolution and motion
I people
this is where I am today I like the
feeling of strength with the pawn on D5
gives me it feels like building a castle
a fortune one goes to D5 it is supported
by his brother on C6 and it comes to F6
for more stability Bishop goes out to F5
the guard outside the gates
eventually the pawn on E6 forms the
triangle for the safest bone structure
in the center it gives me confidence for
the upcoming battle
this is the Japanese
[Music]
foreign
if you want to learn an opening we all
know chessable is the place to go but
what if you want to find out what
openings to learn chassebel is now here
for that too find the openings best
suited for your playing style using
their new quiz whether you want to be a
booked up positional grinder or an
unorthodox tactical visit chasable has
all the answers go check out the
chessable quiz using the command quiz in
chat take the quiz today
and today love on our onion has to do
what is very difficult to do he needs to
beat Magnus Carlsen in the next game he
will start with the white pieces now it
was it looked like a power pack
performance by Magnus but love had his
creative moments that move Asics
breaking open on the queen side he did
play for the initiative if anyone can do
it it is live on our own end he is an
artist let's take a look at the life and
inspiration
in 11 aronians what
[Music]
T-shirts from the movie Coming to
America and it's kind of symbolic that I
am coming to America becoming part of
this country
together with his girlfriend Lavon
aronian has moved into his new home next
door to the chess club in Saint Louis
USA he was first introduced to chess by
his sister at eight years old in Armenia
since then he's come a long way she told
me to play chess because she said okay
you're too annoying and here do
something and then
yeah then I fell in love with the game
Levon had an incredible natural talent
for chess and at only 10 years old the
family became dependent on him to get
food on the table because of the fall of
Soviet Union and the
a lot of problems in Armenia
my father and my mother they were not
earning anything really
so I was earning the money by getting
sponsors his parents sacrificed a lot
during the 1990s life was hard in
Armenia back then so lavon's success as
a chess player was their only hope back
in the day okay I did have some sponsors
but I knew that if I traveled to one
tournament and if I don't play well
I cannot play any more tournaments and
in order to
secure myself which was of course
foolish of me at the age of 15 I would
play Blitz at nights
you know just just to earn some money on
the site you know just to because
for amateurs of different countries I
think this
five dollars a game was nothing but for
me five dollars was a huge amount of
money you can see I'm a popular person
in St Louis
I feel well very welcomed here and
also the people at the club and
everybody that is working
for the club are very welcoming so
is one of the most loved Personalities
in the Chess World but he's not loving
his situation right now against Magnus
Carlton in the losers semi-finals as he
has to win on demand he does start with
the white pieces how does he do this
James what does Lavon have to do in this
one he beat him before we get exactly E4
Best Buy test swinging in you got a
Carroll Khan okay now Carol kaniski here
we're about to swing on him okay there's
a lot of ways that you can swing at the
Carroll Khan pan off bottleneck right
you can go E5 of course Geary got the
new part one so hopefully he was digging
in some chessable there see there we go
let's go let's see what we got now you
take twice and play D4 oh yeah I know
these or you can play D4 right now yep
let's see what we got it's nice I like
this what you think I love it I used to
play this all the time when I was young
and I will point out magnus's score with
the caricon is much lower than his score
with E5 and C5 so maybe not his uh best
scoring opening statistically can Levon
take advantage Advantage okay he's
playing this variation James is this in
your repertoire absolutely of course in
fact you know come on you know I know
chessable like an encyclopedia guys you
can actually get the pen or botany but I
think it's Sam Collins if I'm not
familiar if I'm on correct there but Sam
Collins actually panel Bobby Knight you
can just search it on chessable very
strong I actually have some very nice
wins with this
um OTB and
um and uh online with this now of course
Irwin um Irwin eleme has the the very
nice response I'm giving out too much
right now y'all gonna have to send I'll
give you my PayPal chat okay but I'm
giving out too much but Irwin has a very
nice antidote to this the way that he
plays it but it's very theoretical and
he goes like 25 moves deep so it's very
deep very deep Theory here but there's a
very nice antidote with this it actually
is just Bishop to G4 that's it for black
and then you go down a very theoretical
line also grishek has a p sack line that
I actually use very nice here he plays
A6 that actually comes from um Kristoff
selecki's course
I'm giving out too much okay I'm gonna
send y'all my PayPal but A6 comes from
um A6 comes from selecci's course this
one is not played as much to say the
least oh I'm so annoyed to myself myself
about one minute ago I was gonna say
Magnus is definitely gonna play A6 here
he's played it before online hundreds of
times and he then he does it how would
it looked like a Prophet by myself I did
that you are ready Instagram snap that
we got here right look at this what did
Mario say the GM has Sami Mario
yeah that one wins you know I usually
ignore this Social Media stuff chat but
that's that one's good right Robert's
got his vote in on this one that's all I
need speaking while we will reveal a
winner at the end of the show so keep
those photos coming David you mentioned
that Magnus doesn't have a great score
with the Cairo that's a strange decision
then to go for it in this very critical
match when he just needs to draw it's
all relative Tanya he's got a decent
score with the caragon it's just he has
a fantastic score with a sicilian a
fantastic score with other openings but
Magnus he likes to keep his opponents
guessing and uh maybe he will have just
assumed that Levon had ideas obviously
against his main repertoire so why not
throw in an early surprise Magnus
doesn't care about playing solid chess
doesn't want to play for a draw he's
very principled he plays chess for the
love of Chess and if the results come
great uh but uh meanwhile some tension
in the center Magnus holds his center
with a slightly looking uh artificial
looking move but a very solid one with
his Bishop here and I'll add that by
playing the Carroll Khan he likely
avoided the preparation that Lavon or
only had in store for him today because
maggots does not often play the caracon
Levon likely looking at E5 and C5 as
Magnus has been playing in recent events
so this is a good decision even though
in the Queen's game they say the Carroll
Khan all pawns no hope I think if you're
a fan of Magnus Carlson you hope that
he'll use it with great success because
because his position looks weird with
that Bishop in front of his King spawn
yeah a very odd place to Bishop we
should just point this one out and you
can't get carried away here there is a
trap uh this bishop looking very odd if
you get greedy now and take a pawn it
looks like oh you've won a free porn
you're defending this one with your
Bishop too but the Knight a key Defender
will be removed forcibly here you take
this Knight and unfortunately for black
suddenly the placement of this bishop
and the placement of this Knight comes
back to bite you this is a fork a double
attack and you will lose one of these
two pieces next move so Magnus I'm
pretty sure his uh his idea is to
actually develop this bishop a different
uh route just by pushing his Pawn
forward playing the move G6 and fearing
Kettering this piece that tends to be
the idea here and just as I said he
plays it once the bishop gets out once
black gets Castle to safety then you can
decide how to release the tension
attention in the center there you have a
dude your Prophet moment it's here a G6
you said it Magna is going for
development and how do you see white
preceding because very often white also
delays the development of the F1 Bishop
but is it time now to look at getting
the king to safety
do something it was H4 for the score I
mean you just play H4 that's automatic
you see that with the neural network
engines now and you play H4 all the time
you don't even know what's next you just
play H4 because you can do it right so
H4 is very strong I think I actually had
an OTB game like this that I was
actually winning unfortunately I ended
up losing the game in the in-game there
because I just blunder something back it
was a long time ago but uh H4 I think is
a very nice move here I think Queen B3
you can actually get away with too it's
a very tricky move there Queen B3 and if
Knight A5 you go Queen A4 there's some
very just some tricks through here but I
think H4 is really nice here you also
could play C5 too as well kind of
release a little bit of attention here
maybe bishop E2 that's the quiet way of
doing it but LeBron should not be quiet
here right now because he definitely
needs to go I think maybe all out here
H4 is it's not too committal it
definitely is uh annoying and you want
H5 at some point here but you know I
think Magnus might just play Bishop G7
anyway here we just got to figure out
what we have to do afterwards do we take
do we play H5 to exchange it's not
enough there yet so we just have to see
what happens but I definitely like the
H4 move what about you Robert yeah no
I'm curious to see what's going to
happen here but we do have some results
in the books not in this division
because this is the only match underway
but there is a winner in division three
and it is a main topic to buy the Grand
Master from Iran takes five thousand
dollars and the division Title Here in
the castle Masters congratulations to
him big thing wow and what a performance
he took down
really difficult
to Amin coming back to this position
James you mentioned H4 is it one of
those moves where Thal would say go H4
think later well of course grandfather
Tao always says um if you can see the
resemblance that is my grandfather
absolutely H4 for the score he also said
sack first thing later right so of
course we do want to sacrifice some
material here I actually recommend of
course life and games of Tau which is
unjustable of course it is a testable I
know you're not no I'm going no right it
is uh accessible course you also can get
the hard copy too as well but the
testable course with Simon Williams
actually going through it of course uh
who who's better to do it than Simon
write aggressive chess himself too uh
there I highly recommend you get it and
get in the right mindset of like
attacking chess life in games of Sal and
also the new book out fire on the board
by uh shiroff is now in chessable too as
well I think levon's frustrated here
he's spending a bunch of time he came
into this game hoping to get an
aggressive play you called for the butt
vinnick he went for it but this position
from the black side it looks really
weird there's a bishop in front of the
King's Pawn the kind of Legends of the
game from ascent century ago would look
at this position and roll their eyes
like this is a pots or what is this
Magnus Carlson doing with his Bishop on
E6 but it works out because the center
is well defended and not just that that
white center could be under attack when
you push your pawns forward that leaves
some squares and your pawns behind the
D4 Pawn for example cannot be defended
by another pawn and that could be an
issue later in the game for Levon
aronian yeah for sure I completely agree
this is modern Chess at its finest you
would never have seen this type of idea
years ago but uh Magnus he studied this
clearly with engines he's been playing
this when I was researching for playing
him recently he's been playing this
setup plenty of time so it does surprise
me that love on aronian hasn't come
prepared I think he could have predicted
this position pretty much on the board
if he had studied magnus's games in the
caricon but that's why Magnus is such a
difficult one to put your finger on a
difficult one to trap in the opening
because he plays everything and he knows
everything so well already a four minute
time Advantage almost and uh looking
promising for black I'm expecting Levon
to Castle he wants to channel his inner
tile of course but it's hard in this
type of position unfortunately that's
why openings are so important if you
don't get your type of position it's
impossible to even initiate an attack so
just get castle Levon and then think
later I think that would be my advice
but easy to say difficult to do big
tension in the center in this one and as
I said it has been fixed Levon aronian
decides he doesn't want to take any
chances with that C4 Pawn pushes it
forward to C5 and Magnus jumping in
immediately with the Knight to the
center I was expecting him to bring the
king to safety yeah but he says why not
now because 94 that he's actually making
look at Target of the D4 Pawn because
that was what I was pointing out as soon
as you push your pod you leave some
behind and if white were to take this
994 that would be a huge blunder because
the black takes back the D4 Pawn is
Max's for the taking and that would not
be good news for Lavon so I actually
think that Magnus he's making the right
decision he's getting active while he
can before he allows white to just
expand on the queen side yeah and
difficult dilemma here for 11 Iranian
his Bishop is also attacked his default
Pawn a clear Target it looks like it's
uh essential now to retreat this bishop
defend that pawn but now you're passive
and Black's Bishop here look like a
terrible piece earlier but watch out for
it coming to the G4 Square trading off
one of the key Defenders of this Pawn
later I expect both sides to Castle but
later on the black Bishop will use this
square and black will be able to break
out in the middle of the board so
looking very nice for Magnus uh
levonaroni Retreats his Bishop black
instantly castles Magnus is hustling on
the clock both sides of Castle now and
uh I'm looking up for this move getting
rid of the defender of the the center
looking very good I think I would choose
black here already I've got to say
Black's just so solid it's quite
annoying in fact the pen off is actually
a game that it's usually open positions
lots of tactics and you can get that a
lot but here especially in this A6 line
which is why Christoph selecki actually
an adjustable course recommends this
because it's an offbeat line that is not
played as much the A6 early usually
everything else you've seen Bishop G4
you've seen taken you've seen E6 you've
seen all these other moves the A6 is one
that's not played as much hence why
Magnus played it made uh of course Lavon
think here and now we have a position
where it's usually a little bit more
closed now and this being closed this is
not the nature of the pan off here
especially if you're looking for more
tactics and aggressive aggressive piece
play you're not getting that here black
just seems to be 100 fine we also have
B6 in meaning cases to break up this
Pawn chain that white has so it is kind
of annoying here there is still play d5s
a little weak even B7 but I think we
need to start threatening and doing some
things now maybe the bishop should have
went back to E3 to release some of the
pressure that is on the D4 Pawn now
Magnus is really piling
off Central D4 Pawn currently even
hinting at the picking up one of the
Defenders
is a bishop F3 and picking up that pawn
a big threat does level need to handle
it right now I think so Tanya it's
especially because he's in a must-win
situation it might not be a winning
threat for black but it is a threat to
liquidate to trade-off pieces and get to
safety for Magnus for example if Levon
kicks this bishop asks a question Bishop
takes Knight would happen and uh
actually here if you want to play safe
you just take this Pawn uh you could
even more ambitiously defend your knight
levon's gone in a different direction
but uh what is this he's put his Knight
on the rim is he really trying to come
and trap this rook in the corner The
Rook doesn't have too many safe squares
but he's abandoning his Center what is
this idea Bishop takes Knight
do you have to take with a pawn here if
you take with your Bishop You're simply
a pawn down this white Pawns in the
center drops you're defended
I don't see enough compensation really
surprising stuff
yeah but he did that in the last game
getting his Knights to the absolute Edge
it didn't work out well but David the
big question is what if white recaptures
that Bishop with his own Pawn hitting
that Knight in the center and then
levon's creativity comes to mind with
jumping his own Knight to B6 hitting
that Rook on it is that something that
levon's looking at yeah we'll find out
this move on the board and levonaroni
and he has the decision now will he
capture back with a pawn yes you kind of
Trapped this Rook it's on a really okay
he takes with the bishop I was gonna say
here you do trap this black Rook kind of
but you have such an ugly structure here
these pawns will come back to bite you
to haunt you later on he takes her the
bishop and he's going down a pawn his
idea is to trap uh this Knight now
defended by the bishop his idea is to
try and trap this Rook but I don't see
it working out the Rook can simply move
or you can even start striking in the
center
looking good for Magnus yeah definitely
looking good no tricks no tricks
especially here for people that like
tactics no tricks in the position that's
just going to be tough it's going to be
very very tough here especially just
giving up material no will come I mean
okay you have slight conversation The
Rook goes to A7 after Knight B6 but the
pawn is a pawn and you're playing Magnus
and I'm down time this doesn't look the
greatest for what we want out out of the
opening for Lavon it's so strange Robert
what we're just seeing right now I mean
just down upon what's going on well how
else do you beat Magnus Carlson nobody
really has the answer to that question
so what Lavon is trying to do what a lot
of top players do is they would rather
be down material as long as they have
all the activity and it's going to cost
him this Central Pawn is very important
his the rest of his Pawn structure May
collapse after it but at least he's
going to trap that Rook on the side of
the board that is his hope that's his
intention but Magnus I mean he can just
gobble on D4 and he will not pay a big
price for it yeah we saw it in the last
game as well Magnus was happy to take
some uh kind of strange strategic
decisions in exchange for winning a pawn
Magnus was up a pawn for most of the
previous game and eventually he was able
to convert to Victory it still takes a
lot of skill of course Magnus is capable
but I wouldn't be surprised just grab
the pawn now I think he's just choosing
does he take this white Pawn in the
center with the black dark Square bishop
or does he capture it with the Knight
spoiled for choice he's got a couple of
minutes extra on the clock he's a point
up in this match and uh Levon aronian
body language not positive he just
doesn't look confident today after that
tough start earlier on psychology is so
important at the top level and LeBron
just unable to get his type of position
unable to get uh the dynamism that he's
been craving so far that he knows can uh
kind of be a weapon against Magnus the
initiative in the first game that Levon
had was really clear you could see it
that he sacrificed the bomb but Magnus
was behind development the King was on
castled but here it just looks like it's
hard to see the compensation where is
Love's compensation of magnus's gobbles
a very has the Central Pawn
we'll have to find out yeah it's gonna
happen
interesting yeah it takes with the
bishop that Bishop very strong I guess
he wants to put some pressure both on
White's Queen side pawns but also lining
up against the white king maybe uh
levon's King will feel slightly
uncomfortable due to the presence of
this black Bishop in the center I like
the look of it I think it's good enough
and uh pull it up that's the most
important thing and look at that bar it
seems to say that white is doing fine so
where once again the big question is
does that Rook forcing it do that A7
Square does that give white long-term
compensation of forcing Magnus to
essentially play without a rook for the
next couple of moves we've seen that
happen a big Central break Magnus wants
to get that e-pawn going what is lavon's
next move that we're looking at here I
think I like Queen B3 Queen B3 or yeah
B4 maybe okay Queen beef actually C5 is
hanging that's actually I wanted to play
last move was Queen B3 because it hit B7
and kind of D5 and maybe Rook C to D1
but B4 actually is very strong it it
submits the C pi Pawn there of course
Queen B3 is now a movie can play and
then Rook C to D1 comfortably and have
there's threats towards Magnus here he
has to be very accurate because of
course we have we're threatening things
like Bishop E4 and maybe even Bishop H6
in many cases too as well especially if
you find a pawn E6 is going to allow the
DC sixth Square to be extremely weak so
if we take on e4 at some point we'll put
a bishop on D6 and I mean yeah you got
double pawns you're up the pawn but you
don't really feel that as black there's
definitely uh some holes in Black's
positioning yeah beautiful pieces here
James uh Knight on Bishop just
entrenched in the black Camp so Magnus
has to be careful that's for sure first
move that comes to my mind would be to
throw this Pawn forward but you can't
take back these type of types of pawn
moves for example white will gain time
against the Black Brook whoa I see the
evaluation button the tactics on F2
apparently wow somewhere what the heck
is it yeah there's some little tricks
here still he played it on the bus on
the board wow it's on the board so it's
this bishop move would actually be a
huge blunder maybe the most natural move
in the position yes you hit the Rook but
for example often Knight takes Pawn The
Rook has to recapture the White Queen
attacked and at the very end King takes
Bishop would be met by a nasty double
attack loose pieces drop off this is a
check and the white Bishop Falls next
move so actually actually White's most
tempting move isn't possible Levon has
to trade off the knight in the center he
does so and now I'm assuming he's going
to move his Bishop which direction most
likely this one but on a bit of a loose
square at least he's doubled the black
pawns the front black porn on e4 a bit
of a Target and uh okay I'm assuming
Magnus is going to move this Rook but
he's paused is there something better
will he sacrifice some material I think
he should because nobody likes to play
with a rook imprisoned on A7 so he's
going to give up his King side Rook by
taking this Pawn on B4 and the point is
after Bishop takes on that f8 the queen
can even take back there and the Black
Knight is coming to D3 next uh the C5
Pawn is loose the F2 Pawn is under
attack and if you have to move your
knight just to defend that pawn then the
Black Brook can escape back via A8 so I
actually think that Magnus he should
give up the exchange here wow and look
at our engine suggestion it says that
it's a great suggestion but the only one
that works for Magnus everything else
and Levon is doing fine night before
sacrificing that exchange picking up
that extra Pawn Magnus going into think
he's definitely on that path and he does
it he does it he doesn't like to play
Passive chess geez yeah these top
players when you give them only one move
that's far stronger than all the others
more often than not they do find it just
by process of elimination and here we do
see Bishop takes Rook on the board
Magnus can take back this bishop with
his Queen with his King either way and
as Robert says this Knight is coming in
for the win this bishop actually is far
superior to any of those two white Rooks
that's why you can afford to give up the
material he even takes with the King uh
just keeping full control here beautiful
move and all of White's remaining points
a week this one week this one week for
later and night coming in I don't see
any reply to that one looking very very
strong for black right now wow Magnus
just makes it look simple it's so hard
to play him in positions where like you
may use you think you have something and
then you you know as you see sax The
Exchange here and he actually has the
two strong pawns now even though they're
double but they are both defend or at
least uh E5 is Defender you can defend
E4 by playing F5 a little risky there
but definitely a pawn that you can use
especially for Knight to D3 come back
around take the other Pawn on C5 there
Queen defense tonight on D3 too as well
we're doing things with Tempo which is
very strong here doing things with Tempo
so we need to move fast here I mean it
has to be right now if we do anything
but the question is what do we do right
now Queen to D2 Knight D3 check and take
on C5 doesn't work Knight D3 is coming
yeah I don't think it's stopping I think
I'm actually even more impressed with
him if King takes f8 than sacrificing
The Exchange because you heard me say it
I thought it would take with the queen
that looked way more logical to me but
he says my queen might be needed in the
attack it's putting pressure on that
Knight that's on B6 with the C5 Pawn
being loose it also jumped towards the
king side all the way out in the
diagonal so King takes f8 is a very
Magnus type of move it was the best move
and I mean just not easy to spot for
most mere mortals and Levon has to take
a time out not a move he wants to play
not a happy move but he has to put his
King in the corner it feels like Mission
Impossible at this point it's like
everything you try Magnus has a reply in
store and now again we see the engine
suggestions black has one move that's
faster stronger than all the others the
problem for Levon is that this move is
the most obvious move in the position
Black's Knight is about to jump into the
center to an outpost Black's Bishop is
anchored in the center Black's Knight is
anchored in the center and
I can't see the white Rooks fighting
yeah if you pick up the pawn on B4 with
your knight sacrificing an exchange
you're definitely heading with that
Knight to that D3 Square attacking that
weak Bond and this is looking like big
trouble uh James you mentioned when we
see Levon stretching around that is him
flexing but right now he's not feeling
this yeah he's not feeling he took his
glasses off rubbing his eyes here let me
rubbing the hair you can tell just
stress this is not the Lavon that you
like to see and he's stretching and
doing the neck thing and he stretches
that's usually when he's like
comfortable he's feeling good you see
this a lot in the footage when he's
winning or when he's feeling good he has
a good position here it's not good at
wow King G7 robber I was actually
thinking about this while you guys were
talking there was a tactic there that
perhaps Magnus and Lavon both overlooked
but if we actually analyze I think the
reason he didn't play Knight D3 is that
it looks like there's a pin along the D
file okay Rook C2 if you take on C5 I'm
just gonna take on C but the issue is
that their Bishop takes C5 white cannot
afford to play Rook takes C5 because
Knight takes F2 check it's a fork to the
king and the Queen and when The Rook
takes the Knight that Rook was defend
the queen black not just wins the queen
but wins the game it is Checkmate so I
wonder if Magnus just stop this
calculation and moved too early I'm not
entirely sure but Knight D3 if he had
seen this follow-up it was very natural
just wins on the spot pretty much Robert
wow and uh yeah both players must have
missed this for sure this knight move uh
would have won the game but uh Magnus
instead moves his King to a slightly
safer square away from any potential
checks and I guess this gives Levon
Iranian time to create some counter play
the whole reason he put his King in the
corner was to break this pin so uh what
could be more natural than stepping
forward with the white F Pawn yes you do
allow the black pawn to step forward
creating an incredibly strong pass Pawn
but if black spawn does step to the
square the Black Knight at least can't
jump in to the center anymore so it's
not one-way traffic and that's a good
sign for level on Iranian this game
still alive and he very quickly does
play F3 will we see Magnus jump in with
his Knight now we'll move too late or
the pawn step forward I think those are
the two main candidate moves but uh
still I slightly prefer black but
yeah missed opportunity and if Magnus
does decide to step in with the Knight
lavender onion could be the one who's
thinking about sacrificing an exchange
by capturing that Central Pawn opening
up the f file is this one tempo too late
going to count a lot
could do okay he's moved his Rook up one
square and uh Robert's idea is it still
in the air Bishop takes porn right now
setting that nasty trap there's some
tension along the default the two queens
staring off against each other
indirectly and uh it looks possible to
me there might be some tricks that white
can try however in return this one is
getting complicated this one is
sharpening up live on with four minutes
Magnus with five this move F3 I think
was a good one from Levant he's not only
trying to undermine the defense of that
Black Knight on D3 trying to open up the
f file the white Rooks need lines to
attack on and if that pawn captures 94
there is an open Line towards the black
king so this is what Lavon is banking on
that Knight on B6 can be captured but
there's going to be a pin down the D
file and thankfully for Levon after
Knight F2 check he has that second Rook
that can capture because the Rook on D2
blocks along the defile you can't take
the Rook enough to you lose your queen
so this would actually be a good
situation for Levon when he needs to win
the game yep uh this looks like the best
shot for level Iranian right now Magnus
here would most likely block with his
Bishop push a pawn I still think black
is solid enough especially when a draw
is a decent result but at least he's
complicated the issue here Levon pretty
much needs to take this Pawn remember
this trap Rook takes Bishop doesn't win
a piece it actually loses the game to
this Knight Fork so level and of course
he'll spot this tactic he'll spot this
trick and uh process of elimination you
pretty much have to take this Pawn
and hope for the best so let's see what
he's done okay he does capture and
Magnus I think will now take that white
knight off the board it was too strong
trapping that black Rook so eliminate it
and the game goes on
this one getting tense I thought Magnus
would wrap it up quite quickly but we're
still going
I've got time to I mean uh oh um he's up
time he's up about a minute and some
change here right so better clock
management from Lavon here and a
position where I mean really it's really
playable for both sides after this Rook
G2 I'm up to The Exchange you have to
remember that is some material and it
takes some accuracy I can't play B6 or
B5 yet that actually you know covers
that whole rank the whole seventh rank
there because Rick D2 Rook takes and
maybe a rook D7 if we get these three
moves in we do have some serious counter
play ourselves wow yeah this one uh I'm
just trying to work out what happens if
black drops in a night check yeah that
wasn't on my Radars because look I was
too kind of Carried Away by looking at
the White Knight that's uh the song
please right now it's edible you can
take that white knight off the board but
there is a nasty check that can throw in
and you've got to recapture that night
with the queen side Rook otherwise you
just end up losing your queen yeah and
there are consequences maybe we show
this on the board uh what Magnus is
considering right now because of the
match match situation is can he force a
draw for example does he flick in a
night check after The Rook takes this
Knight he trades off the Queens white if
he takes the queen back will lose his
Rook uh to the black Bishop this is on
the board wow so Rook takes porn pretty
much guaranteed this is the position we
have and uh here okay Levon takes back
uh the black queen and black is a pawn
up I don't think there's too much to
worry about this actually is the game
position sorry and uh
we do a quick count it is five points
against four points this should be
enough for magnets to hold and the black
Rook is at long last going to be freed
because the Knight is booted out of B6
which means the B7 Pawn will push
forward The Rook can slide along the
seventh rank over there so I feel like
this is going to be good news for Magnus
Carlson he only needs a draw he's up a
pawn and his Rook will get some
Breathing Room yep that's the key the
Black Brook once it gets out no problem
pieces for black nothing much to worry
about looks like a good kind of
practical play practical decision by
Magnus that could have been better but
uh why not get to this very safe
position I mean the only thing that it
looks like Lebon can try and do is
somehow Checkmate that King on 86 it's a
far away dream but is that possible in
some alternative Universe maybe
but uh yeah I guess it's gonna be very
difficult you need a lot of moves here
and these moves just don't seem right
especially with the night where it is
but it's clear right James what he wants
he wants to just make sure The Rook
doesn't come out into activity ever so
Knight C8 sort of a last try to keep
that Rook out of the game also attacks
the bishop on C5 still keeps that over
alive maybe push the pawns G4 H4 maybe
start with H4 and then try to box him in
as much as we can
now we mentioned that black Rook it was
about to uh finally come to life but at
the moment at least it's still a bit
stuck I really like this resourceful
idea by 11 aronian he's so creative even
deep into the end game it's touching
upon that point earlier he doesn't solve
things like most would in the end game
he solves it with tricks with tactics
and look at the evaluation bar creeping
up slightly for white back in the middle
now that black Rook still needs several
moves it needs to push Pawns in front of
it to break free and okay just a pawn
push himself 11 aronian the white king
may be getting ready to join the action
this one's not over yet that's true
there isn't me there isn't it James
okay all right H you get a G4 you've got
H4 then G4 then just slightly slowly
walk to King up and then G5 King H5 and
Rook H7 is mate now of course this is a
long shot but hey what else do we have
I'm losing anyway you know what I mean
like I need to go for whatever I can
make the chances take the chances while
I can yeah draw is the same as a loss
here for left on Iranians so if you just
needed a draw he would maybe move his
Rook back win a pawn with a white knight
trade everything off and head into a
rook end game but that's not sufficient
okay here he's trying to just block up
Black's play Black's Pawn pushes on the
queen side Magnus sliding across with
his own Rook you've got to go for
checkmate yes now whenever there's
nothing else to do it's really the only
way you've got to move that bishop and
push the B Pawn while he's doing it he
is coming with his King forward we might
just see a meeting net on the king side
but it does feel a little too slow yeah
it takes at least three or four moves to
set up uh to push these pawns forward
trap that black king how does Magnus
unravel in the meantime the problem for
Magnus is that if he moves his Bishop uh
he would love to push this Pawn forward
to get his Rook out but the pawn is
needed to defend this piece if he moves
this bishop which he has just done I was
gonna say the Knight could get out he's
moved it in the right direction if you
moved it to the other diagonal the black
uh the White Knight Springs back and
suddenly uh ideas against this black
king but uh it's still trapped look how
dominant this bishop is over the White
Knight cutting across this diagonal
taking away Escape squares Bishops
overnights that's what they said what's
uh what they say in end games yeah long
range piece here Bishop covering many
important squares and finally at long
long last The Rook is free and once The
Rook is out that should eliminate most
of levada changes but he's still trying
to get that checkpointing now he hears
you James he's saying oh if I can make
that King I have to go for it I need a
victory in this game but Magnus is no
fool he is not just gonna allow those
pawns to walk up the board and deliver a
Checkmate he first brings his Rook up he
can then pin the pawn if the King goes
up to the third rank so I feel like
Magnus has this one under control Yep
this is a key moment if he doesn't pin
this white Pawn if the white Pawn steps
forward definite threats on the board
but uh that's it yeah yes and Bishop E1
here from from Magnus so we have to
watch ourselves I mean the Knight is a
short range piece versus a long range
piece being the bishop it is uh it's
very very difficult to make anything
happening what do you even move the king
is this just all draw now you pick up at
night and put it on F6 and that's one
zero
Ivor anywhere near that black king for
the white Knights and you might even win
with whites but the white Knight's so
far away it takes three four moves by
that time black has gobbled up all of
your pawns under one minute I think he's
realizing that he's just one or two
moves too short
it's like tough brilliant play for
Magnus once again I mean just playing a
brilliant precise I mean the great
Magnus first day except until today 100
you know 180 there he's just playing
much better every day he got better from
the first day to now we see a very
different Magnus right now he's in the
zone Bishop E1 is coming we're up a pawn
I mean no mate the Knight is on A7 so
far away from any action it takes at
least two three moves and we don't have
another two three moves we can't allow
Bishop E1 and Rook takes G3 or Bishop G3
King G4 runs in the bishop E1
immediately and like it's very very hard
to play anything here nine seconds
yeah oh dropping down under five seconds
now level of ronin he needs to move he
needs to Hope just move that King do
something and what has he done Retreats
the whole way yeah that doesn't feel
right but you had to stop this big
threat that you were pointing out of the
bishop sliding to E1 attacking the G3
Pawn it's the only way to keep the game
going right this there's a look of
resignation on his face he kind of
wanted to just give up the match but he
has to play on a few more moves but
Magnus deserves a lot of credit he's
well nourished after all those meals
that he's had on stream now and I think
that he is ready to compete and he will
have Hikaru Nakamura up next it's only a
matter of a few moves that he'll ice
this one take it through to the next
match up but Magus he really played a
great match as James was saying yeah and
Hikaru at this point knows it's nearly
definitely Magnus that he'll face uh in
the next round so he'll be doing his
preparation he'll be watching this game
with serious interest but uh that one
looking very dejected that David he's
just shaking his head it's kind of hard
to even point out where the match went
all wrong for Lavon Magnus it's made it
look so easy yep that's uh the top
players in the world before you live on
he hasn't made any blunders at all just
tiny little uh small details here and
there and that's the margin at this
level
poor level and I feel for him yeah so
close against anyone else he would have
had great chances today absolutely
yeah unfortunately Magnus too strong and
I'm expecting him to either get that
black king off the edge of the board and
that removes any chances of Checkmate or
to relocate that black Bishop you can
still Target some of White's pawns near
the king uh if you find the right
squares the right diagonals so what will
Magnus choose
plenty of choice here you can also go
hunting with his Rook for that white
Central Pawn for the white Pawn on the
edge of the board but okay he's
retreating his Bishop not the most
accurate move the engine thinks but
still should be more than sufficient for
the required draw
they do say a good horse never jumps as
high as they have to so at this uh at
this level if they only need to draw
players know how to lock it down and you
know you're an equestrian but right now
I think that you see uh Magnus you know
he's just making these precise moves
because he doesn't want to give a lot
any hope here but both players are under
a minute and that's when mistakes do
happen if that Knight starts hopping
around it could be a fork that is
overlooked and the black king isn't
fully out of danger just yet nice move
there from Levon maybe missed by Magnus
white holds all the pawns and suddenly
the White Knight jumping back big threat
Black's Central Pawn Under Fire
yeah and the bishop still isn't
attacking that King Side Pawn anywhere
and you've got to find a way and he says
I'm gonna get my king to safety Levon
immediately grabs and it's a big blunder
because you lose the G3 pawn and you
lose the game yep that's a wrap you know
he tricked him oh no my Pawn Eric
rosenstyle take that pawn the game ends
because through that night is the G3
Pawn levana Ronin he looks at his
position is hopeless the game is over
yeah wow love on our Union resigns
there's no way to save this position
after the G3 Pawn Falls the game is over
Magnus Carlsen wins his match 2-0 to 11
aronian after that first aid disaster
Magnus does look Unstoppable what a
power performance today by Magnus and we
see their Lavon not happy with his play
he is looking dejected there it just
looked like he never got things going a
critical big fight Magnus what about
back performance it's time for our Lee
soweta learning points
foreign
point is about not being materialistic
to do a scan of the board and to check
maybe sometimes there will be more
important priorities than saving
material in this position Magnus as
black is a pawn up against level
nerodian his Rook was Under Fire most of
us myself included would have been
inclined should simply move this Rook
out the way however white would now have
time to Simply defend the queen side
pawns and the position is very balanced
white has activity because this black
Rook is trapped however Magnus he'd seen
deeper into the position he realized
that this black Rook wasn't doing
anything anyway he saw it was more
important to grab a pawn and after the
dust cleared we saw this position the
Black Knight is coming in this black
Bishop is worth far more than the white
Rooks and he later went on to wrap up
the game just to show the final position
it was here the black Bishop was the one
indeed doing the work after it slid back
x-ray vision against this Pawn through
the White Knight and next move Rook
takes Pawn will Checkmate or will win
material nice game by Magnus Carls
very nice indeed alert from start to the
end and that means that this is a score
line Magnus Carlsen with a dominating
performance against Levon aronian
winning two games not just the score but
also the performance that he had over
the board just his style of play today
there was no chance for Lavon aronian
and that means that we have set
ourselves up for are the most
anticipated match it will be Magnus
Carlsen taking on Hikaru Nakamura on the
other side of the stretch break
[Music]
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess Mastery Magnus
Carlson introduces chessable the
definitive solution for studying chess
move trainer uses the science of space
repetition to identify your strengths
and eliminates your weaknesses there's
no need to set up a board remember which
page you're on or keep track of all the
moves you miss move trainer empowers you
to go from the opening to the end game
with confidence
seamless effective and fun way to study
chess choose from one of the largest
online chess libraries in the world with
hundreds of titles ranging from classic
books through to our exclusive chessable
courses including over 100 free courses
get expert insights from International
Master John Bartholomew Grand Master Sam
shankland International Master Christoph
selecki Grandmaster Simon Williams world
champion Magnus Carlsen and hundreds of
other instructors get started now and
join our growing community of over one
hundred thousand chess enthusiasts at
chessable.com
accessible take control of your journey
towards chess mastery
[Music]
I used to worry
I would wake up all day I
[Music]
had more to say
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
[Music]
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem so do you think you have what it
takes to compete in the international
Quant championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
hey card Nakamura he cannot lose and he
has to win either this one or the next
one
there we go we have it Gary the G Pawn
makes an appearance G5 he's going for
magnus's King the bar is inching up for
Magnus Carlson with the white pieces
what's happening can the black Rook make
Headway against the lone white king is
Takara winning you're more distance from
the king so the King goes to D3 you see
the bar go back to E equals react to
Karu as well oh my gosh Magnus Carlson
should be able to hold there we have it
game three is a draw
and that moves almost as nice as that
trophy here's that pawn where two white
pieces can take it that is beautiful
tactile awareness from Magnus Carlsen he
is really earning this Championship it's
over we have a winner Magnus Carlson
takes it he wins the air things monsters
the fans love it commentators love it we
all love to watch this and match up they
do have so much history clearly the two
best players in the world when it comes
to speed chess and chess in general
there we see they're Head to Head
they've had some epic clashes in
speeches over the last year Hikaru
Nakamura with 20 wins and Magnus Carlton
with 29 wins last time they played was
the air tanks finals that one David
Magnus took it away what are you
expecting yeah Magnus took it but the
margins were small uh their previous
match earlier in the tournament was uh
down in Armageddon and Magnus had those
result odds at the end there but I'm
expecting this one to be equally close I
do think Armageddon is the most likely
it's just the stakes are so high will
the players risk it in the first two
games I'm not sure but uh either way
there will be drama and there will be a
winner
James do you think Hikaru has been
watching the action that's just happened
absolutely been watching everything in
it of course and he always says I
literally don't care right but of course
uh it's going to be He does care and it
is going to be a heavyweight matchup
people take off work wherever you are
around the globe to watch when Hikaru
and Magnus play hundreds of thousands of
people are actually 100 000 plus every
time they play It's the biggest event
almost as big as the world championship
do you think is the reason for that why
is this always such an epic fight rabbit
well you have the retired chess player
the biggest streamer chest streamer on
the planet against the best chess player
on the planet so of course we're joking
about hikar being retired he literally
doesn't care as you see on the screen in
front of you but this is a heavyweight
matchup and it's in the losers bracket
oh my God and Robert you did mention it
on day one you predicted this that in
the final we will not have a repeat of
the other things Masters but this is the
second best thing that could have
happened we do love to watch these two
beasts go at it it is hard to pick a
favorite but David how hot is it today
it's hot should we make predictions oh
we gotta do it let's do it we gotta do
it I'll say Nakamura oh hot dick I'm
going with
um Hikaru oh I'm surprised I think the
losers run continues for Magnus he lost
in the first round I think he keeps
winning since then yeah I've got to
agree with you Robert he's just been on
fire Magnus Carlton after losing to our
time you have he's won match after match
and then beating Wesley yesterday in
style and a dominating performance today
against Magnus but Hikaru there on the
screen he doesn't care he almost looks
like he's just woken up yeah he just
took a nap he just woke up right there
in the chair you can tell absolutely and
he got the shirt literally doesn't care
look at that little nap another nap
get some sleep he's doing that Jedi mind
trick just resting his eyes so he's
fully focused for the fight ahead I'm
gonna sleep you're sleeping
wow wow Magnus practicing his artemio in
a magic trick
period right now Magnus Carlton we are
waiting him to don't do that
do how Magnus Carlson prepared I think
that I would be a much better chess
player so I have no idea I think he's
probably in some food snacking a little
bit and next thing you know he's gonna
be facing off against Hikaru he won't
have much time to do anything but play
the game yeah gotta love that food
Gambit but the big question is what are
their strengths and weaknesses David
what does uh Hikaru need to do to win
this one and where will Magna strike so
Hikaru just needs to stay in there he
knows that actually if the clock does
tick down he's got decent chances he's
one of the fastest hands out there in
speeches online chess he's got so much
history so much success uh Magnus I
think the opening is important for him
but also if he can get those grindy end
games put Hikaru on the back foot
continuously throughout the two
potentially three games if that's
Armageddon then he'll have his chances
but uh yeah we're getting ready to start
going I love it I love when this clock
starts sticking and release that's the
tone for the game that's about to start
what a big matchup and that we see a car
is still waiting do you think he's
getting a little impatient there oh no
he's just yawning
it's quite early in the US right you
know what it is actually what let's see
what time it is yeah it's like noon in
fact well he's in Florida so that's a
little bit different decent time is 11.
it's noon so it's past noon there for
him so he shouldn't be tired yeah and
did you see that where did Magnus just
suddenly appear from yeah nobody knows
he lost our time you have now he learned
that's what I'm saying you don't lose
you learn
I love it Magnus Carlson and Hikaru
Nakamura will be starting in just a few
moments best of two there is no margin
for error if it ends in a tie we will
have the Armageddon when these two play
it goes down to the wire is that what
we're expecting today will there be an
Armageddon cool you know what I don't
think there's going to be an Armageddon
it's only two games so I mean hey look
one guy or one of these guys who's
winning the draw I think is not going
down Armageddon it is going to be
something crazy today that's what we're
looking for that's what the fans want to
see right but the fans do want to see
Armageddon 2 as well so it's going to be
a shake up here I see a tactical
Wizardry and a resourcefulness from
Hikaru but also Magnus it's very slow
calm but also can be tactical sees
everything Universal style so it's very
very strong chest here yeah we know you
found all of you out there love these
two players tell us in chat who are you
rooting for and keep those selfies
coming usually using the hashtag chess
Champs and Hikaru starts with the white
pieces money for and we've got the
camera again this time David are you
more surprised
um I'm even more surprised I've got to
say I thought Magnus would revert to
maybe a different opening strategy
Nakamura for sure would have been
watching that Clash against aronian that
Magnus had a few minutes ago so he would
have known the caracon is coming in
Nakamura he had this on a previous day
if I'm not mistaken against Vladimir
fedes uh the Queens are off early on and
James I saw your face react to that one
yeah we've got to focus on that we got
to get our camera on James right now
this is ridiculous bro don't nobody want
to watch this like everybody falling
asleep man people took off work to watch
this you know what I mean yeah I know
what you mean but I also see this battle
between Charizard and blasters look at
their colors they are the evolved form
of the game and they say let's get down
to the end game hakar doesn't want to
take risks against Magnus he just
watched what he did to levona Ronin he
watched what he did yesterday to Wesley
so let's remember Hikaru nakamura's
yesterday he lost two and a half to half
to five undercarwana so after that
result I think he wants stability in the
first game stability in the first game
but in this match format you get only
one white when Magnus will play for
white he with white he will be more
aggressive going into an Armageddon is
that a math strategy is that what Hikaru
is hoping for two peaceful draws and out
there in the Armageddon yeah I think he
wants Armageddon because in Rapid time
patrols Magnus is the stronger player
between two we saw their head to head
record nine more wins if I'm remembering
correctly for Magnus Carlson so look at
the early stage of this game game it's
just development nothing major has
happened just yet but I think that is
sort of an opening win he's won this
opening battle for Magus Carlson yep and
uh he's caused the first surprise
firstly the karukan Magnus it's clearly
his opening of the day but uh also just
to play so quickly into this end game uh
the Queens are off we call it a
queenless middle game just for the
benefit of the doubt just because it's
still exciting what's Magnus up to there
uh closing the blinds
chess players uh prefer the dark the
night owls and uh yeah Magnus he's
caused the first opening surprise I do
expect him to be extremely well prepared
you don't take the Queens off unless you
know exactly what you're doing here's
black otherwise you just get a
prospectless position you just get
slightly worse slightly cramped white
stretch or very nice I do expect Magnus
to develop quickly to go for this white
king that uh is stuck in the center at
least temporarily well the good news for
white is that one of the pieces either
the Knight of the bishop can hop onto
that D3 Square in front of the Knight to
just block that D file to make sure that
the pin is not very dangerous so things
still under control I like that Hikaru
is taking control of the long diagonal I
see that eval bar though it does inch
towards black why is there this slight
nag in the position for black
I'm confused too it looks like white is
super solid Black's doing fine of course
too but I would have assumed that this
is a totally level position with best
play is there something direct has move
would have been important here I don't
see a knockout blow well magnetize a pin
this Knight 92 and I think one of the
major issues for white is that you have
to block this pin he does with his own
Knight but that light Square Bishop is
now blocked by the Knight that just
blocked the black Rook so blacks pieces
more naturally developed C5 is a great
choice he vacates the C6 Square for his
Knight and I think the development it's
a win for Magnus I really like how his
pieces are getting out of there hikaru's
pieces are kind of awkward at the moment
yeah this is actually gross to say that
laser right it's my favorite word to use
here when you're talking about positions
here and I mean the reason being
practical of course C5 was an excellent
move my Bishops are out okay if you want
to take on F6 cool give me the bishop
pair I'll take it all day I'm Castle
you're not we're just going through like
things in the position I'm castled
you're not my Bishops are developed
yours aren't really okay maybe the
bishop on B2 your night's kind of
strange right right C4 it could be
possible especially if you move the
knight from D2 you got to move your King
again after I've already made you move
your king in that castle my Knight's
gonna go to the Natural Square C6 right
and then I can also maybe even double
the Rooks I just have natural peace
placement natural peace development and
Etc and black actually just seems to be
a favorite here in practical sense yeah
once it's just stuck completely stuck I
just don't see any kind of productive
move right now of course you would love
to get these two out the way you'd love
to move your king as well but where do
you put it if you move your king forward
you block this bishop even further if
you move your king to the side your
Rooks will never be connected and never
get into the game and meanwhile obvious
what Black's plan is as both of you
mentioned there the Knight is coming
actually into a nice Central Square
potentially
it feels like he's messed up his move
order somewhat and it's actually white
on the defensive surprising normally
here we would be talking about a white
safety white Advantage even but it's the
other way around yeah I don't like this
for her car I think it's also
stylistically not what you should do
against Magnus it looks like he was
playing I don't want to say for a draw I
think he was just trying to get a
position but the position that he has
received is not good his pieces are not
harmonious his Rooks are not connected
and will not be for the foreseeable
future and Black's development the other
hand is that straightforward as we've
been discussing so I really don't like
the look this for hikar on the board but
also on the clock he settlements behind
in the early stages yeah I'm really
surprised I mean Magnus playing with the
black pieces starts with the Cairo makes
two two moves with that c pawn and here
we are talking about it being better for
Magnus that feels like some sort of a
Wizardry it's not normal he's playing
Hikaru Nakamura one of the best in the
world and it's hard to point out where
white went wrong
I think the opening choice in fact
they're absolutely just going for the
queen trade he usually when I saw Knight
F3 I'm like oh he's gonna go for the two
nights variation because he does that a
lot especially in title Tuesday against
the Carroll Khan I've seen many
excellent two nights games from him
Knight F3 after D5 he goes nice C3
you're going to the two nights Carol
Connor favorite of Bobby Fischer's as
well and I mean I've seen him do it with
a great success against very strong
players but he went with the D3 line and
then after takes takes takes and now
we're in this position right
do you think that solid approach uh
Robert is backfiring a little bit for
Hikaru here well he started Sally but
his last move is anything but solid he
pushed his Pawn forward to F4 to block
the diagonal that the dark Square Bishop
is on for black but when you push pawns
forward you leave squares behind the G4
square a knight can hop into there at
some point soon the E4 Pawn is a little
bit loose so I feel like F4 it makes
sense to block that Bishop to gain some
space for white but also will cause some
long-term problems yeah you don't take
that one back anytime soon Magna still
has the very simple idea in the near
future I'm not sure whether immediately
or in the next few moves of just
plonking a knight in the center still
difficult questions for Nakamura ahead
if he gets time of course he will not he
would love to solidify this Pawn chain
this nice little uh Trio here but
weaknesses on the squares around them
definitely still white on the defensive
and uh meanwhile I did get distracted
for a second I saw some of the twitch
comments about Blastoise versus
Charizard water type does beat fire type
so uh Magnus is he the favorite here so
I said from the beginning that's why I
use those Pokemon it's not just you know
Fire and Ice we see the red and the blue
come on it was intentional it was
intentional that's right uh which
Pokemon did Magnus say last tournament
was his favorite you asked him right
Robert did he say Psyduck Psyduck yeah
Psyduck wow yeah I think that was
Pokemon as well yes it was yeah
what a psychic type yeah I can see that
from Magnus ic6 and G3 we have those
move you called it David he is trying to
get that Bishop about but then creating
these light squared weaknesses how
quickly can magnets take advantage of
that G4 square is it time to bounce on
it already
feels that way if Hikaru does get a few
more moves if White's light Square
Bishop gets out the way if the white
king steps forward to a safer Square the
Rooks connect then all the opening
problems have gone for Hikaru Nakamura
and actually if anything I would say
momentum white because Black's Bishop on
the edge of the board the dark squared
Bishop is extremely stuck you might need
to take a step back with that but then
you lose time so it does feel like now
or not at all for Magnus if he wants to
claim the opening Advantage any ideas
Sir James Robert
I do want to point out that this Pawn on
C5 the black pawn there is under attack
it has been under attack and right now
because the pawn F4 got a second
Defender I think white is about to snap
it off the board so perhaps black has to
invest some of his own time to defend it
but that's not what you want if you are
Magnus we were just talking about how if
hikara finishes development he can fin
Kettle his light score Bishop get his
King off the first rank at long last the
Rooks will get connected so I do think
that Max he wants to operate quickly and
he does he pushes the pawn forward that
is upon sacrifice white can snap it up
with his own Pawn don't pick it up with
the Knight because the odd the Central
Pawn gets weak but wow is Hikaru going
to accept this yeah if you take with the
Knight just to put your move on the
board there Tanya this looks pretty good
for black this night now threatens a
bunch of things including a nasty night
Fork on F2 uh I think he has to accept
it that is the answer I don't think you
really want to move your knight out the
way it does feel super risky to allow
this pin uh to
well it's gonna lead to bad consequences
simply I do see checks in the immediate
future for black and this Knight might
even get trapped later on so you simply
have to accept this gift and the
question here for Magnus is how to
compensate for the temporary Pawn
deficit these of course are weak pawns
on the queen side Magnus at some point
will simply go for them but does he go
for them immediately or is there
something even stronger not sure maybe
something like Rook a to C8 we've seen
this a lot from him uh and you actually
learn a lot from watching these guys
it's almost like free lessons in a way
is what I always like to tell the chat
like watch and try to learn from every
game that you see from these players
here I mean he sacrifices the pawn you
take with the pawn and then you just
follow up say hey this is long term you
still got to move your king you have to
finish your development my development
is completed it says black and you have
a weak pawn and I also went attacking
the pawn on C4 I mean I can move my
knight to A5 increase the pressure I
think it's an excellent choice here for
Magnus yeah I love it we've seen a
sacrifice right out of the opening in
every single game today that's the mood
the players are in and this is kind of
identical to what magnets did against
Levon he gave up his sea pawn and
doubled his opponency upon isolate them
so Magnus he just did this an hour ago
let's say he's doing it again in Hikaru
he's stuck he has to take this Pawn I
don't think he has another option than
to take with his B3 Pawn Yeah and uh it
was Man vs curtain there for a moment so
it looks like the cut and one Magnus
gave up and came back to the board but
uh meanwhile yeah he goes immediately
for that pawn Hikaru realizes process of
elimination again he had to capture uh
on the C4 square with his own Pawn but
now full of weaknesses full of holes the
white position if you look at the white
half of the board the first four ranks
everything's very loose there yeah and
uh I do fear for Hikaru if he doesn't
survive the next few moves we mentioned
it earlier Magnus needed something there
and then he found something interesting
and now it's Hikaru that needs a defense
here and now and uh I don't see it if
the pawn is just taken back then long
term white is suffering he'll have those
fractured pawns on the queen side
yeah really nice play by Magnus I've got
to say this is ugly I don't like this
for white my king is like right there
you see you feel another Rook coming to
the file there I mean you need some some
Chemistry Between the pieces like they
need to be developed nicely like if the
bishop was on G2 the C4 is hanging like
there's so many things it's just it just
feels very wrong here from the white
side there's problems that need to be
solved in White's position yeah I wonder
if you just step your extra point
forward that white C Pawn is going to be
doomed anyway the first uh the foremost
C Pawn so why not Step It Forward at
least hope to survive Live Another Day
and at least ask Magnus how are you
going to continue with your initiative
but I don't like it either eight minutes
on the clock for Hikaru he's been caught
out in the opening with white not a fast
start for him
opening more files what would that be
good for a car is King is stuck in the
center uh black will have multiple Rooks
in that area of the board the white
Rooks are not he pushes his e-pawn he's
attacking a knight to a very direct
approach from Hikaru that Knight should
just move away it can hop forward into
the G4 square but it might get trapped
so be careful when you decide to go for
an attack for a fork of your own because
if your knight wanders too far let's say
after Knight G4 white plays King E2 and
black makes some random move I don't
know A6 something on the queen side H3
traps that night in this place yeah you
could even take on C4 and still get
trapped so it's a very tricky position
and Knight G4 is so tempting because
you're jumping in with the Knight but
Magnus calculates and navigates he does
fall back one of those things he only
retreats to go forward next yeah if he
gets time he might even come to B6 with
his Knight and capture uh with the
Knight on C4 but okay Hikaru stops that
he keeps his Pawn alive his extra Pawn I
don't think it's gonna lift for much
longer you can go after it with your
rook and it will eventually fall or it
should eventually fall but he might
continue clinging on for dear life
Bishop to A3 I'm saying that same thing
Bishop A3 this is a very aggressive Pawn
structure and the pawns you got the nice
uh wall over here right uh pawns on the
king side and then the C5 Pawn you
actually can defend I mean weirdly
enough I am just holding him you can't
really get everything yet my knight is
holding it maybe if I can get Bishop G2
in and then but where does the King goes
the question maybe King C1 or you are on
that diagonal of the H6 C1 diagonal
still thinks the answer but I mean it's
looking a little bit better looking a
little bit better for white White's One
Connect Four at least that's the
specific
you mentioned Connect Four and I want to
ask you guys is there an idea in the air
for actually Magnus to strike with G5
opening up that Bishop you don't have F5
in the air is that something that Magnus
is thinking about in the position
absolutely why not you want to open up
the position on your own term so G5 it
might initiate a pawn break that could
be beneficial but a card brings his
Bishop this is blocking with your face
change 100 face block is premium wow
Bishop D4 for the score look at all
these pieces on the file now what he's
saying is I'm gonna play C3 and lock it
down clown he's gonna put it right there
in the center of the board that's a very
strange structure David put Pawn C3 on
the course yeah what is going on on that
D5 like a random move here or something
like A6 again and then and then let me
look at look at this structure you know
don't try this at home okay guys no I'm
gonna try this at home right but it is
actually harmonious in a way the pieces
all do something they're all kind of
coordinating here and then we have to
figure out how to slowly untangle this
but I mean there are Palm brakes which
Roberts always talks about Palm breaks
control the game there's B6 there's F6
there's G5
I want it I I know you'll be happy with
it James we need G5 on the board you
want this one Tanya just to break down
this structure
doesn't hit it that's the good news
right yeah right if I was a strong I
like it I'm a big fan of that stuff and
it does break that pawn structure up
like you talked about it really does and
I think Hikaru that's the type of move
he would hate to face right now
especially as the clocks tick down if
one Pawn disappears it's likely the
whole edifice the whole chain will fall
uh later in the game so I like that I
also like chipping away at the other
pawns on the queen side
I'm not going to support for choice but
he's important down and again it's that
theme we mentioned earlier today the
longer that kind of uh that doesn't
clarify itself the longer you can't gain
your Pawn back the more you might sweat
later in the game but I really like
James's point because something where's
commentaries often do is we suggest
moves and Jane has mentioned three
different Pawn breaks he said Ponder B6
Pawn to F6 Pawn to G5 so if you're
analyzing this right now look at all
those Pawn breaks to see which one is
best Magnus chooses B6 F6 that was a
there's a valid reason for that as well
and I like the fact that he's playing on
the queen side because white is
unprepared to meet Knights hopping
forward the bishop on D4 The Rook just
eyes it from d8 so I like the initiative
that black is building here and there's
a lot of pressure aimed towards White's
camp yeah it just feels like a CaRu is a
lot behind in development the king not
feeling very safe on that defile you've
got three minor pieces well now two but
still all of magnus's army just
perfectly placed to Target that white
King on the clock as well Magnus Carlsen
ahead by two minutes how tricky will
this be for Hikaru to defend he is one
of the most resourceful players ever
that's the thing earlier you asked about
strengths weaknesses defense is one of
hikaru's uh main Fortes in chess he just
never gets flustered even when his backs
against the wall even when he's forced
to retreat pieces like he's just done
with his Bishop he's still confident
that he can unravel later on and kind of
work his magic against the opponent the
problem is when you're facing a super
strong opponent like Magnus they will
not back down every move will arrive
with a threat and if you just slip once
it might be game over magnus's last move
I'm not sure exactly what it does but it
does slightly improve Black's light
Square Bishop I think he's just trying
to tie down white light Square Bishop
it's counterpart to the defense of these
knights in the center look at that the
two black Brooks so many Targets on
these open lines more than enough
compensation but is it enough to win I
think that's the question for Magnus
Carlsen one huge problem is that
psychologically it's very difficult for
top players to give away a bishop for a
knight but at some point soon maybe that
moment is now hikara will have to take
that Knight on B6 just as I was saying
he does it because that Knight was ready
to hop forward and into the white
territory so that was a great decision
by hikara and maybe on Magnus he moved
his light Square Bishop he should have
hopped his knife forward first yeah and
suddenly uh Hikaru has at least one
active piece this white Rook that's just
shuffled across to the semi-open file is
attacking Black's lone remaining Pawn on
that Left Flank on the queen side so uh
Hikaru he's being greedy he's one Pawn
up he wants to go for a second but why
not everything else seems to be holding
together for now and uh tania's idea
from earlier I think it might appear
shortly black the only problem piece in
the position is that dark Square Bishop
so you need to break it out of jail
break it out of prison and if you get it
active the two black bishops might just
win the game so I'm looking out for
Magnus to do that shortly I'm not sure
whether it's now or later but uh he
needs something he needs to keep
pedaling it's like on a bike if you stop
pedaling you might fall off and you're
reporting down
that's the case here I'm actually trying
to figure out how what is the more for
black do you play Rook B8 or Rook C6
Rook B8 is very passive it seems like I
am down upon I'm not really trying to be
passive Rook to C6 defends it but then
maybe it's hit with Bishop to G2 oh you
know what oh my goodness there's there
might be Rook C2 there let's show that
James wow Rook C6 you just want to
defend your Pawn first and foremost uh
why not but after the bishop moves
suddenly tricks in the air uh yes your
Rook is attacked but you can move it out
of the way and I guess the question here
after Bishop takes Knight this is the
trick you sacrifice The Rook you've
gained a knight next you gain uh maybe
not this Square I'm not sure which
square is best for white let's say this
one uh but at the very end the dust
clears it's level material maybe draw
with best play but this black bishop's
still a sad piece yeah wow yeah versus
the word it's a good variation but so
maybe looking at that which is what
Magnus is calculating he might play in
the starting position the move E6 that
Bishop needs to see the light of day and
it can go back through f8 it costs him a
second Pawn The Rook can't take the pawn
on B6 but we know magnets he loves
active pieces and here his Bishop comes
back into the game and it comes back
into the game and it will use this
diagonal I'm not sure which square but
it will use this diagonal later on to
exert its influence yeah I still like it
white is tied down this Rook not
participating so temporarily at least
Magnus is playing with an extra piece so
despite the two-point deficit definite
compensation uh Magnus now in the tank
dropping below Nakamura for the first
time in this game really and anything
could still happen yes the evaluation
bar slightly prefers black I slightly
prefer black but I could see this
turning around uh some of the variations
we showed there actually white very very
safe and still material up Magnus
looking away from the screen for a
second there calculating something James
calculation over everything that was his
calculation face that's right
calculation over everything I'd like a
Magnus I see four what is this takes
takes
channeling your inner Nakamura there
takes dates and uh the knights are off
but a pawn another Pawn drops off the
board two-point Advantage for Nakamura
that's crazy the eval bar is not even
moving like okay barely moving down two
pawns I guess he's getting one back and
some initiative interesting yeah Bishop
pair often compensates for one Pawn so
if Magnus can get one of the pawns back
he will still have long term uh yeah
long-term compensation Nakamura I still
don't like where his King is placed the
Queens are off the board but the white
King's still sweating feeling
uncomfortable yeah and that rock on the
other edge of the board the H1 Rook far
away from today the bishop not developed
a lot of compensation and Magnus does
have the bishop pair Hikaru doesn't even
pretend to defend that A2 Pawn he says I
need to get my pieces into the game next
he wants to push that King one square
ahead perhaps and just bring his other
Rook into the game try and double up on
the open b line yeah it's important to
bring that Rook into the game because
not just about the material white
temporarily two pawns up black Magnus he
could take this Pawn A2 right now to cut
that deficit in half but the point is
that when white gets that coronation
that one extra Pawn will be felt if you
get a passive there if a car decide to
bring his Rook back and defend he would
not have had his pieces in the game so I
really like this decision from icaro I
don't think Magnus is in big trouble but
David is you were just indicating before
the longer the game goes where one side
is down material and the more
coordinated the pieces become that could
be a long-term issue for Magnus all of a
sudden yeah for sure at least
psychologically and we can tell that on
the clock times Magnus is feeling the
pressure burden to do something to win
pawns back to maybe clarify the tension
and maybe even to push this game towards
a draw earlier we were talking about
Magnus trying to win now I think it
should actually be a switch of focus and
Magnus needs to play Safety First chess
you can't keep on gambling your two
pawns down if you keep taking risks
White's pieces will come to life and uh
yeah you might regret it so just take
that pawn back why is he thinking right
now and uh yeah Hikaru doing everything
right such a good Defender never panics
okay Magnus going for the idea that we
highlighted earlier firstly dropping
that black Bishop back to a more uh
promising diagonal but also that G5 push
that Tanya mentioned watch out that
might come later well if the king
definitely moves forward to activate
that King side Rook I am expecting
Magnus to blow up in the king side with
that cheap one Advance whether that
happens or not we will see but Magnus is
still delaying picking up that extra
Pawn on A2 is there a good way for
Hikaru now to defend it or he just lets
it be and brings that Rook into the game
the top players in the world they very
rarely go passive for the sake of a porn
or two often they do have other things
on their mind first of all he's
preventing any contemplating no more G5
not fair gutted but I think that was it
was tempo for Tempo again for Magnus
because hikar didn't really want to put
his Pawn on H4 and what Magnus has
accomplished is he can reroute his
Bishop back to f8 use an open diagonal
so A2 should probably be captured right
now but in terms of the last move for
each side that was an advantage for
Magnus even though ultimately Hikaru was
doing just fine in the position though
the G3 Pawn that's on a dark Square only
black has a dark Square Bishop so if
that Bishop can reroute via C5 to F2
there could be some danger for white
yeah long term if you imagine everything
coming off the board if black starts
picking off one Pawn especially the bass
Pawn on G3 everything will fall so still
some hope for Magnus long term whereas
Hikaru I think it's time definitely in
the near future to start stepping
forward he's done it and activating your
Rook he's done it and Magnus surely now
better late than never just take this
Pawn why not okay actually be defended
if you don't take it now when has this
extra Pawn too as well I mean like
practical chances especially as time
gets lower and Hikaru does have a slight
Edge whoa wait a second check step out
the way this white king is doing a dance
set with death right now it could get
trapped on the background and that was
important he could probably be in a lot
of danger if he would have stepped up to
the E3 Square because potentially then
black could have snapped up that Knight
on D3 and stepped back with his own
Bishop giving a check so lots of dangers
and an attack with the bishop pair for
Magnus this looks very dangerous all of
a sudden the white king is actually in a
meeting net and so Rook takes A2 is
about to happen and a card does not look
particularly thrilled you see his face
he is diving into his laptop screen
because let's say you play Rook B3 you
want to get that Bishop out of there
blackhead ignore it black can take this
Pony too you get the bishop guess what
I'm getting your Rook that Rook that has
not moved in the corner it will never
move because I'm snapping off the board
hey Robert be doing his taxes every day
Chad make sure y'all doing your tactics
puzzle Rush okay put your puzzle Rush
score in the chat make sure you do your
tactics every day that was a nasty
tactic there Rigby three is a move a lot
of people would actually make in this
position it attacks the bishop but Rook
takes A2 yeah Rook takes A2 and that is
such a big threat it needs to be
defended it needs to be defended now
only one move to stay in the game for
white or to uh avoid a losing position
that's to shuffle your king across and
defend this Pawn oh that looks scary as
well the king's not safe here either
James he finds it what happens on
doubling the Rooks yeah doubling the
Rooks the back with the Knight and
defend the A2 Pawn is nice you wanna
move it looks awful yeah it does look
awful but it defends exactly that is a
huge fine for a car that's not easy
putting your king into Harm's Way just
so you can Retreat your knight
retreating moves often the hardest to
find in chess but Hikaru has kept
everything together in if indeed rookie
has played he'll step back with his
Knight that's why Magnus has not made
his move yet yeah ugly moves are better
than bad moves after all so uh sometimes
you need to play those types of moves
just to hold things together and uh
Hikaru shows no bias that's why he's so
good as well he's happy to stay flexible
he'll play an ugly looking move if it's
necessary and White's still two pawns up
so even if you have to play these weird
looking retreating moves you have
something to hold on for you have a
reason to be optimistic for the future
what about Bishop takes first then yeah
that looks very tempting as well James
uh yeah I wouldn't be surprised if he
goes for that or if he's calculating
that right now Magnus Carlson two
minutes though on the clock and he's
still two points down remember will he
okay he's going for a James your idea on
the board Bishop D4 and now he's going
to go for that pawn surely
two pawns down actually which way is he
going he could go for those white king
side pawns that we mentioned the black
Bishop could go and hunt those dark
squared Pawns
options for black but uh still two pawns
down the stakes are higher for him I
reckon right now at least over the next
few moves uh Magnus Carlson needs to
speed up yeah Carlos just played
amazingly this defense in a very
difficult position this is what makes
Hikaru Nakamura the toughest to beat his
resilience and resourcefulness is second
to none what is going on here that's a
great move by hikar there you have to
Choose Wisely he was going to lose upon
no matter what and you see his Rook on
the third rank now defending this Pawn
on G3 so he gives up his d-pawn it was a
backwards Pawn he said that is a less
important Pawn because if G3 Falls so do
the rest of the punt he's giving up the
Central Pawn because the base on the
other side of the board on the king side
is still defended yeah still defended if
you keep this one intact you will not
lose this game so uh okay what is Magnus
is there a nice little trick if you pick
up that pawn with the A4 rook and Rook
F1 just trap that Bishop on F2 whoa
Square this bishop is trapped actually
if you take either way with your Rook if
you take with the other Rook as well
he's done his trap oh my God and
Nakamura is getting really interested
now this bishop is trapped let's go back
to them
yeah so the email bar didn't jump much
there has to be something what happens
there's a Saving Grace because black
will bring the Rook down to D2 okay so
it takes oh and then double wow yeah
you're gonna double in the second Rank
and maybe white can't make progress if
Magnus saw this somehow I'm not sure he
did but if Magnus saw this ahead of time
that is brilliant that is I mean really
prophecy right I look at garu he's
figuring all of this out because Rook F1
does trap magnus's Bishop but on the
other hand the white Bishop also ends up
getting trapped that is incredible
calculation by both these players and
that means it's still game on opposite
color Bishop but I think draw isn't the
most likely result
oh this one is crazy and I think we will
see this on the board if not we'll put
it on the analysis board actually while
Hikaru thinks let's put it up because
this is about to happen it's what he's
thinking about is what he's calculating
at least the most natural move in the
world trap your opponent's bishop and
here actually I think black only has one
move to survive he didn't go for this
here black incredibly needed to give his
Bishop up on this square if you brought
your Rook back you are losing Rook takes
after a capture on this Square
apparently white is winning with a nasty
check the king moves and a Saving Grace
Bishop to see oh
I think both players might have missed
this I could forgive them this would
have been difficult I don't think any
human with one minute on their clock
would have found this for example Rook
takes rook and white emerges with an
extra Bishop missed opportunity for
Hikaru maybe yeah definitely we're
definitely only move was Bishop takes G3
wow instead we have this position and a
set of Rooks are about to be traded
watch out for these pawns Hikaru needs
to be very careful if this Pawn
disappears black will be the one with
winning chances and I look at her Caro I
think he just figured it out that he
missed this it's possible he looks he
doesn't look happy with what's what's
just happened that is clear yeah he kind
of uh called magnus's Bluff okay the
Rooks are all disappearing Magnus leans
back and breeds the sigh of relief does
he think it's a draw it is a draw they
agreed on it so he doesn't have to think
anything they agreed on the draw on the
position and wow that was actually wild
that was some heat that was some heat
right there tactics way there at the end
Andy Carl got away a little bit in the
beginning there Magnus has some pressure
on him Wild game we got another one
coming up yeah look at the car I think
he did see that moment at the end of it
throwing his hand in the air what a big
missed opportunity he could have trapped
magnus's Bishop David take it away yeah
it was all about this one moment only a
few moves from the end of the game the
players saw agree to draw after all the
Rooks disappeared opposite color Bishops
do have a very drawish tendency but
while the Rooks remained on the board
that was anything but the case here
Nakamura the movie was very focused on
was this Rook Slide the black Bishop is
trapped but maybe here he assumed that
Magnus had this drawing resource by
attacking the white bishop and then
pinning the white Bishop two Rooks on
the second rank after all extremely
dangerous but this killer move here by
Nakamura I think was missed a rook check
getting the Rook out the way clearing
the diagonal to hit this black Rook it's
sadly on a light square and actually
after the dust clears white would have
been winning Magnus would have had maybe
better defenses but a missed opportunity
nonetheless by Hikaru Nakamura
though the queens were traded off early
on what an incredible fight this was
could have gone either way and with that
it means Magnus Carlsen and Levon
aronian they draw their first game going
into the second one if that's a draw
then we'll have an Armageddon if either
one wins this they go through to the
Grand Final before that action starts
for our non-subscribers we've got a
twitch break coming up but for those of
you who have subscribed stay right with
us
foreign
[Music]
ERS in the world and she was in
Reykjavik open here with the transport
team revealing some opening secrets
hi I'm Alexander botas and I'm in
Reykjavik I've been preparing for every
single opponent here I'm really lucky
because I'm working with Grand Master
hammer and he's incredible at
preparation so I wanted to use this
tournament as a way to force myself to
actually study chess so I think my
openings are way better now than they
were before
I have an incredible coach and he
actually told me that the preparation he
gave me this tournament is better than
the preparation he gave Magnus when he
was helping him the execution of my
preparation was good and lines I'm more
familiar with and it was more difficult
and openings that I completely switched
to and had to figure out anew
which told me I have to stop playing the
king's Indian I know it's terrible so I
found an opening that was even worse
and I don't know if I'm going to
continue playing it but at least I know
the theory better now
wow better opening preparation than what
was handed over to Magnus David any idea
who that could be
um if Alexandra didn't reveal the name
I'm not sure I should but
uh very well-known Norwegian player all
right we'll keep you guessing wait who
is that but we also want to wish
Alexandra a sister Andrea bootes
professional streamer and a professional
chess boxer a very happy birthday from
all of us here in the studio well right
now we all can be very happy because
we've got another game coming up in the
match between Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura the score is a level what were
the big takeaways from that game one
Robert the biggest takeaway is that Kara
Nakamura literally does not care usually
but I think he does after that game he
seemed to spot the tactic that he
overlooked it was really tough to find
in the moment but maggots he too
probably looked with the engine after
the game was like oh that was a close
one very close call there for Magnus
Carlsen who could have been in big
trouble if Hikaru Nakamura would have
found that tactic in the end trapping
magnus's Bishop what a moment that was
but Magnus picking up those spawns
Hikaru sacrificing two pawns out of the
opening these players are playing very
aggressive and what's with the yawning
oh yeah he doesn't care literally I mean
literally doesn't care right you got the
coffee there okay let's see him take a
nap before we he got on here today but
uh playing he can't nap at the board
okay kidnap at the board here with that
crazy game that just happened both of
them understand that they are dangerous
and lethal and it can be anybody's game
now we really saw that strategies for
this match we saw Hikaru just happy to
take pawns happy to play a really quiet
solid opening and then just defend but
Magnus was the one trying to make things
happen trying to play on the front foot
and uh actually was nearly punished for
it later so will we see that same
strategy in this game Magnus has white
will he be the one again initiating the
play will hikara be the one reacting
defending
two extra bonds foreign
Magnus managed to keep the initiative in
the first one the clocks the countdown
has started for our Play Zone which
means that the players will be in action
in just a few moments Magnus Carlsen
starts with the white pieces what are we
expecting
Catalan
Catalan okay I'll say English opening
I'll say E4 I'm going with Robert
and then Hikari laughing is it because
magnus's played a strange unexpected
first move
was he just uh literally enjoying the
moment
yeah we will have the first opening
moves very soon from the players Hikaru
waiting as well
he could also go for what he did with
Lavon right start with the English
opening and then just pick up once well
if a car offers him that then he
certainly will go for it he had a good
position he won that game against Levon
but I think hikar is looking for more
solid openings as black
will we get an Armageddon shot tell us I
am excited about that it would be a lot
of fun to see the Mind Games between
these two with the bidding Armageddon
bit before that Hikaru Nakamura with the
black pieces taking on the world
champion and it's 1D for the Queen spawn
opening oh so uh I'm wrong Robert Tanya
it looks like James might be the one to
call it but will it be the Catalan okay
no no it looks likely to be the nimzo
Indian there we go Black's Bishop coming
out pinning the White Knight this is the
nimzo and uh Magnus employing this very
trendy variation blocking the building
did you see hikara look and now his paws
he looked into the camera with a little
bit of smirkling oh Magnus you slide dog
he was not expecting this specific
opening today and it doesn't look like
much all Magnus did was put his Bishop
in front of the queen blocking the pin
on the diagonal but it changes the
dynamic of the game yeah it really does
and uh I don't remember I don't recall
Magnus playing this one either so a
small surprise early to start this one
Magnus loves the bishop Power white has
a very strong dot Square Bishop that's
why Hikaru jumps into the center of the
board with his own Knight it's worth
spending one or two moves here to remove
those Bishops potentially and uh here
black is the first to Castle and now how
does he fight against the White Center
how does he erode that white uh strength
in the middle of the board very often in
these positions black ends up trading
the Knight for the bishop and then
striking in the center just liquidating
that Central Pawn structure eventually
white could end up with an isolated
Queen spawn are we expecting a trade and
then a central break Hikaru Nakamura
says no I'm going for another plan keeps
the tension on the board yeah and one
thing I will say is I've seen Hikaru
have this exact position before with the
black pieces at least once or twice so
Magnus will be prepared and look at the
speed with which he's playing he's
immediately pushed forward in the center
first really balance Magnus has the
space he has some more advanced pawns so
Hikaru needs to fight against that and
he's looking at his opponent's plan
right Hikaru played B6 so he could feed
keto his Bishop so what does Magnus do
he closes the diagonal before the bishop
can even get there while gaining the
space that David's talking about so
Hikaru does not develop his Bishop yet
he first slides his Rook over
anticipating a capture on the center
yeah and Hikaru that's uh opening recall
face number 304 just staring up to the
right and remembering his opening
studies his opening prep there which
chessable course James oh of course you
know I would know that I actually was I
was out of theory when he played B5 I
couldn't remember what the theory was
I'm looking up too like what was the
theory after D5 but everything was
correct even up to B6 and 94 rookie 8 is
nice keeping the tension the chest of
course that this comes from is actually
from storyaga and goalie um in the uh
lifetime repertoire semi-terrash but
this is actually the nimzoo one it's
part two actually one of the greatest
courses on there on the nimzo you also
got another Nims of course that comes
from um wfm Mikey m-a-i-k-e I think
that's what it is but it's called The
Fierce dimso also comes with a fierce uh
a Fierce and another one it comes with
this two courses that come together on
that but that Surya one is definitely
the one that's a GM course part two he
recommends 94 B6 Bishop B7 in these
lines so so pretty good from Hikaru so
far oh impressive uh encyclopedic
knowledge again James gotta say and do
you think nakamura's been studying those
courses you know what no not at all
literally doesn't care right I know so
especially uh when he was playing uh
that uh what was he playing that weird
Bishop D6 stuff in the uh rosalimo that
yeah he just he wasn't looking at no
courses because it was pretty ugly when
like he was getting some bad positions
in that but here this is pretty good I'd
actually like the rookie eight keeping
attention here's what they say keep
detention many times you will end up
taking this bishop on C3 at the right
moment you're also going to play D6 too
as well because uh we take when you get
rid of the dark Square bishop or when
you get rid of one of your Bishops one
of the rules is obviously put the pawns
on the square of the bishop you traded
so making moves like D6 and maybe even
E5 at some point even playing F5
sometimes you can really steamroll black
and actually make this bishop look
really bad you don't even have to take
it sometimes the Knight will actually go
from G uh from E4 around to G5 and F7
play a really aggressive like when
making the bishop very ugly on C3 so
lots of ideas yeah really flexible
structure for black as you mentioned
it's all about whether you take this
bishop at some point and Magnus is
trying to figure out whether he can keep
this bishop whether he can preserve it
later on or whether he can at least
provoke this Knight to make a decision
this Knight really does clamp down on
White's options you don't really want to
push this Pawn forward to attack this
Knight because it weakens your king and
now we see maybe the reason behind that
because nakamura's move he has opened up
some lines for his Rook towards the
white king So Magnus is a bit stuck he
needs to get rid of this Knight somehow
but without it coming at the cost of his
position yeah and the cost of the clock
he's almost been in a two in a two
minute Think Tank right now after this
little move rookie lining up The Rook
against magnus's King his Magnus feeling
a little uncomfortable right now
certainly and Nakamura meanwhile having
a nap
he really is having a nap right now I'm
literally an app I literally don't care
about my nap
I'm good I'm good I mean they say you
snooze you lose but her car is showing
that he could take a nap and still hold
off Magnus Carlson but in this position
Max is trying to determine what he does
with his pawns and that light Square
Bishop on F1 it hasn't moved it's
blocked by its own night he can try to
fin Kettle that piece but it comes at
some risk because you keep moving Pawns
in your position you leave some squares
behind and I think Magnus maybe he's not
familiar with the opening I know it was
his choice but it might have just been a
one-off decision without actually
knowing the theory behind it yeah and
that's the cost sometimes if you haven't
played openings you can study them all
you want but if you haven't played them
you might not be familiar with the ideas
and what a move James that's spicy I
mean you know I'm that's a my alley all
day H4 and then Nakamura starts he said
something to himself like what is this
bro what are you doing but it's very
aggressive and I like the idea one
Bishop pointy he wants the other one to
go as well I mean even I was actually
thinking this too I was like okay maybe
not maybe he won't go for this I was
actually thinking Castle Queen side you
see this a lot in the uh Knight F3 B3
lines early on with Bishop to B2 this is
like the uh the Kali type aggression
where even the Shaq Madeira actually
plays very aggressively with the Knight
F3 B3 lines Knight F3 move one B3 move
two Bishop B2 move three he actually
ends up playing C4 sometimes playing
Queen C2 and casting Queen side throwing
the g-pawn up the board Bishop goes to
D3 literally just trying to blow you off
the board so it's actually it has some
reminisces of that where the Knight can
move he can play Bishop D3 Queen Z2
Castle Queen side literally launching
all on attack yeah
that is an aggressive move by Magnus
that it's almost like when in doubt play
H4
and uh how serious is this is he
planning to March down with that H Pawn
all the way to 86 if he gets the chance
or David is this more of a way to get
the Rook into the development with a
rook lift I'm not sure Tanya I hate it
I just don't think you can break the
opening rules like this look at the
white light Square bishop and Nakamura
has the opportunity to open the center
when the center can blow open like this
can you really get away with playing on
the flanks you're not really attacking
anytime soon that black knight in the
center on e4 so beautiful so glorious as
well
I prefer black I've got to say whatever
Advantage Magnus hopes to have it's very
long term but his King is in the center
so this game may not be very long if he
doesn't figure it out because what we're
seeing is this Pawn in front of the
black queen it's backwards it can't push
forward and that could make it a Target
but that white King on E1 it's not
castling Queen set at any time soon
because the Knight on e4 hits that pawn
on F2 the king needs to stay put
defending the pawn diagonally across
from it so this situation does not look
that friendly to Magnus I know he went
H4 it may seem like he's the one
launching the attack I think he didn't
know what to do he said this looks
interesting let's try it hmm yeah that's
the feeling that we got and David black
always has the option to actually pick
up that monstrous Bishop on C3 I don't
see an attack do you no I think Magnus
was was perhaps inspired by Anish Gary
who earlier today in division two
defeated Dennis lazovic with uh an H4
Pawn push in the nimso Indian but here
it just isn't the same type of scenario
for anyone at home I recommend checking
came out that nice win by Anish Geary
and in the second game of his match
against denlaz but here Magnus okay he
switched from that attacking idea
pushing his H Pawn forward well that
mysterious idea I should say and now
he's gone to positional measures just
improving the white Rook uh now we can't
Castle Queen side James disappointed
definitely disappointed 100 uh no of
course uh I do understand Rook D1 though
Rook D1 what it does is he you know
you're stopping the Bishop from moving
Bishop B7 is The Logical move let's put
some pressure on the queen there of
course you can't really move the bishop
the Knight yet because it would be
hanging or at least the uh there's
actually wow bishop b794 and ic2 is made
is that serious whoa my goodness just
show that James we have to show that
that is mate that's disgusting yeah so
uh Nakamura played his Queen to E7 very
logical standard move uh Bishop to B7
this would have set a nasty trap Queen
takes porn boom Knight D4 that's
disgusting you've been doing your puzzle
Rush James oh every day every day
absolutely breakfast lunch and dinner
and uh this queen now and The Rook they
are disconnected acted if Queen takes
Queen for example intermediate move
Knight C2 Checkmate me on the board even
Queen B7 the same thing yeah Queen B7 as
well Knight C2 Checkmate and maybe
missed by both players you've got to
think uh not an easy one to spot from
afar but uh this one Nakamura is still
in the air for later he's first moved
his Queen nasty variation James he's
clearly been doing his workouts both on
and off the board but you mentioned Miss
giri I just want to give a quick shout
out to Anish he did beat you Yang Yi and
he moves on to face Maxima Sherlock in
the losers Final in division two the
winner of that matchup faces Notre back
Abdul sitarov the Uzbek teenager the
former World rapid Champion the Olympia
Champion he is already in the Grand
Final so the winner of the super gym
class will face noribbeck in the grand
final tomorrow
yeah big names everywhere big names big
games and uh Magnus H5 James oh yeah I
knew this was coming you have to be H5
right and you want a rook lift you know
I'm saying do you even Rook lift are you
hitting the gym with the Rooks or not
right H5 and then we when we live right
Rook H3 looks good you want to play
Maybe F3 at some point but that's really
gross so you have to be careful there's
even some sacrifices like Bishop G7 at
some point I need to get my pieces out
though this is the problem I want to
move this Knight but he's going to take
on C3 almost every time he stops you
with H6 it's I mean G4 you might as well
like you might as well at this point I
mean Magnus just out of his mind right
now I like it though but G4
I have a feeling it might be the Rook
lift uh at some point over the next
couple of moves because actually if this
Knight disappears then you do have
access to some really nice squares going
towards the black king but Mysterious
Play by Magnus ambitious play we're
gonna love it definitely yeah creative
stuff
Magnus Carlsen with the aggressive H
Pawn but it has been stopped for the
time being by Hikaru Nakamura how
dangerous is a potential sacrifice on F2
is that something that Magnus needs to
watch out for
potentially actually wasn't even on my
radar though you mentioned Italian now
I'm super scared but unfortunately it
doesn't work for black yet it also
whites move that's why I think advancing
the white Rook to the third rank
covering some squares holding on some
pawns getting pieces into protective uh
defensive uh kind of formations before
anything bad happens to the white king
it makes sense because I'm so scared of
what Tanya just suggested I might even
bring my queen back two squares because
the queen on D5 it's not attacking
anything it's actually vulnerable it's
susceptible to being attacked and James
showed some cool Checkmate attacks for
black because the queen would be loose
so Queen back to D3 that also vacates
the D5 score I want to bring my knight
up to F4 and into D5 at least I'll have
one active piece and that's an outpost
Square for whites pieces and that
protects E3 no night sacrifice on F2 I
think after the queen drops back to D3
finally white can start developing yeah
I really like it just uh bring up the
night yeah and defending this bishop as
well so that uh Knight takes Bishop will
never come at the cost of kind of
shattering those white pawns really
sophistic dedicated move there Magnus
will he switch from kind of attacking
ambitious play though to uh more kind of
calm measures that's the big question
look at the clock as well he's putting
too much pressure on himself Magnus
Carlsen to create something sometimes
you need to take your time out play
sensible kind of easy natural moves
instead yeah it's the first time today
all day that we're seeing Magnus being
the one who is behind on the clock there
again sakaro with seven with about seven
and a half minutes uh Robert your idea
and Magnus goes for it he says that D5
juicy Square my knight belongs there
that's why I love commentating is
because sometimes I can guess the move
that Magnus is about to play but I get
Help from My Friends you always
suggesting really good ideas and because
I was so concerned about this Pawn F2
and I didn't want to do a rook lift so
early because I didn't know where my
king would go process of elimination led
me to a queen D3 I think it's a great
decision and it's difficult for players
once they're all in on the attack to
take a step backwards magnic saying I
need to play the position not the
mentality he brings the queen back the
night will be be able to jump forward as
David was highlighting the pawn
structure will not be shattered if that
black knight takes the dark Square
Bishop on C3 I really like this movement
not just because I suggested I think it
allows White's pieces finally to get out
yeah really nice harmonious move now and
Nakamura needs something himself long
term black is struggling especially the
backward deep pawn and James your trick
is on the board won't be gone let's go
yeah tactics of breakfast lunch and
dinner we got him wow
David well Queen takes porn if you get
greedy you might live to regret it
Knight D4 James throwing it in the way
if this Knight is captured by a pawn the
White Queen drops Queen takes Queen if
uh you take the enemy Queen Checkmate
smothered mate and uh that King is
suffocating behind its own pieces but
amazingly to even right so that means
that white has a continuous version with
Rook takes that night it's a crazy line
it is bro I see this is sickening to me
The Rook D4 even works how is this even
a thing so you give up material and here
I guess you take back with the bishop
and despite it being the end game it's
level material then get out of here this
ain't equal I get this off the screen
there's some email bar engineer fix that
bar
you know I'm up in exchange bro
Magnus isn't taking on D7 I don't see
this happening I mean the alternative is
Knight F4 and he hasn't played it yet so
you know he's calculating oh I told him
I told you you gotta be kidding me he
was thinking so he was taking his time
he actually loves end games like this
where there's a material imbalance he
actually I believe knows with certainty
that he's not worse in this end game and
he's gonna try to win wow it went right
down this line bro yeah let's just call
this it's on the board I'm a Jedi I'm a
Jedi I'm a Jedi yep that's right but
this is like this doesn't make this is
crazy it's not like any sense at all
yeah so we should that's really cool bro
what
a recap material count now black has a
rook white has a bishop and two Pawns in
return so level material but of course
extremely imbalanced blacks Rooks look
pretty good I've got to say white has
some weak pawns at the moment can white
get organized that's the question but
dearly you sound as balanced right
because white has got the two pawns for
the exchange but who does it favor
positioning is the exchange going to
Khan more or the minor piece activity
here for Magnus you would think the
Rooks but white dark Square Bishop is a
rock in the center of the board it plugs
an open file if the black rocks can't
break into White's position then white
pieces might creep out a bit later on
especially that white knight if it can
find itself on a good Square I think
Magnus has decent chances we've got to
trusty evaluation by this level but I
think I would choose black oh I'm
starting to agree with David initially I
said oh wait it's Magnus Carlson playing
he's sacrificing material but that C4
pawn it sticks out like a sore thumb and
I feel like Hikaru is going to be able
to attack it either with his light score
bishop or even with his Knight sometimes
you drop the Knight backwards to put
pressure are on White's loose pond so I
feel like here Magnus has to find two
three accurate moves otherwise he might
be significantly worse wow a big
critical moment and far Magnus Carlson
will he be able to make the most of that
centralized Bishop on D4 the dark Squad
Bishop can't beat challenge he does
bring his Knight into the game eyeing
that D5 Square he still needs a couple
of moves to finish his development a
will Hikaru strike first and make the
most off that C4 weakness the game
really does depend on the next on the
next maybe two or three moves and it
could be very decisive yeah and now
would be a good moment for Nakamura to
pause and invest time on the clock he's
got a four minute advantage in the bank
and I think now is the time to spend it
because if you don't find something
white light Square Bishop comes out
White's Rook might lift uh James will be
happy with that one and I think there'll
be no problems at all for Magnus Carlson
if anything the game could turn but
Black's Rooks need to get active black
needs to strike here and now actually
like 96 here I mean I'm a fan of the
tempo right 96 is tempo I hit the pawn
make you do something you either defend
it or not I mean I'm gonna take if you
don't and I'm also threatening something
like Knight to F5 as well I want to get
I want to attack this bishop if B3 I
maybe have B5 in fact actually just to
try to maybe you know loosen some
squares there maybe after a taste I
might have Rook C1 in some cases here
right you know it's already some trouble
here but it's a very nice I get some
activity so I'm a big fan of the tempo
here and make things you attack as much
as you can especially having uh his
development lacking kings in the center
Bishop on F1 you haven't developed a
rook on H1 the faster I can developer do
things the faster you can get in trouble
I may even have B5 right now right so
there's lots of possibilities for black
but again as you mentioned David that
using his time this is the time to use
it right now yeah and uh just as I
predicted he is wisely spending his time
that's why he's so good Nakamura he'll
Blitz you he'll uh kind of rush you on
the clock when he needs to but he also
knows exactly when to pause this is a
critical moment because we've just seen
that transformation of material and the
top players when there's a
transformation whether a simplifications
trades captures threats attacks that's
when they pause and work out uh kind of
get their bearings on the position I
like your move uh there James retreating
the Black Knight
and uh Magnus looking very calm at the
moment but I think inside he's actually
slightly nervous about this exact
position
big decision here for Hikaru will he
strike immediately with the beep on or
attack the C4 Pawn how fascinating is it
that both these games have been very
quick Queen trades and still so rich in
complications yeah because the players
are not trying to necessarily make a
quick draw if they were doing that they
play the Berlin line that we see hikara
and Wesley play all the time but instead
we see games that just have an ambiguous
start and then the players are on
neutral territory and we just saw hikarp
drop his Knight back so he's clearly
playing for win and Magnus needs to be
quick here right we keep talking about
it he has given up a rook but he has a
bishop and two Pawns in return if Magnus
was castled could protect this Pawn C4
he would be better here I like the pair
of Bishops in the center I just think
that he's a little bit behind in
development yeah and uh you could see on
the frown on magnus's face that he's not
comfortable slightly too slow here to
get everything he wants from the
position and uh on your note Tanya
they've played each other over 100 times
in Rapid chess I don't recall any boring
games any boring drawers really uh
unless it suits them both maybe in a
tournament situation but that's always a
fight always imbalanced both of them
always going for each other that's why
it's such a popular matchup uh between
these two uh yeah Titans exactly that's
why we love to watch both of them play
we've never seen them settle for a quick
draw even without Queens on the board
that's exactly what we saw in game one
and here as well they are going for each
other's throat now remember if there is
a decisive result then The Winner Takes
the match and will enter the Grand Final
if it's a draw then we will have an army
Garden a big threat on the board
currently the C4 Pawn is under Fire
Magnus Carlson thinking how can he
defend it does he need to defend it can
he start looking for activity already is
B3 going to appear on the ball God are
you expecting that David yeah to be
honest I wasn't really considering
anything else but as you mentioned Tanya
maybe you can go for activity yourself
as white maybe it's time for that Rook
lift for Magnus to show he's been doing
the hard yards and uh to move this Rook
up the board for example you could
Shuffle it up and if the Knight takes
the pawn suddenly you slide and counter
play against the black king look at how
strong this bishop is I love this piece
maybe the MVP right now for white
attacking this Pawn uh with the rook and
the bishop of course black can defend I
should mention by dropping back with
this Knight that's why I think Magnus is
pausing otherwise he would definitely go
for this active continuation and uh
suddenly the Black Brook would have an
open file it's not just the pawn
dropping it's more the open file but uh
still interesting option for white he's
taking about 200 minutes he's down to
three
three on the clock
positions
he will have to take some more critical
decisions in in this game those extra
seconds are going to count Magnus
Carlsen drops below three minutes that
was very very important here I mean you
don't care who you are I mean even
Magnus has a problem like of course
Magnus lost to Hikaru in the speed test
Championship right this is Championship
but I mean it's getting in speed time
territory in fact for Magnus at least
right you can't you you can't do another
three or four minute think actually as
Magnus here at least I mean from Hikaru
I actually have two maybe three more
three two to three minute things that I
can do right now so I mean this is huge
huge time Edge for Hikaru here and you
know he has this is a critical moment
I'm also down in exchange I need to be
precise I need more time to think about
this I think he I think practically uh
Magnus is in a lot of trouble right yeah
is he sensing a little blood here he
certainly is he knows he has the better
chance here and you see Magnus he just
gave up his C4 Pawn I think he wants to
just continue to connect his pieces and
now he's going for opposite colored
Bishop I think there's a great practical
decision by Magnus Carlson the bishop on
D4 cannot be touched by that Bishop on
B7 they're on their own color complexes
and a light Square Bishop in this
position what's it going to attack I
think this is fantastic understanding by
Magnus he's trying to minimize the
damage and I do think he's accomplished
that yeah fully agreed and he's putting
Pride to one side as well here it's most
likely white just playing for a draw but
that is far safer than the Alternatives
where it was chaotic where he had two
minutes on the clock and now Magnus is
King Super safe actually on this Square
on G3 everything defends each other if
you notice the white Rook can take care
of itself all the pawns though are
defending uh are defended by pieces and
all the pieces defended by pawns they're
kind of helping each other out so Magnus
looking very solid uh despite the fact
he's down on material now it's still
that white Bishop playing the most
important role keeping the black Rooks
at Bay and NACA switches focus with his
Rook you better take that boy you better
take that Bishop that Bishop's so strong
I mean that's the strongest bishop ever
you're actually right I mean in fact
like you can never move it that is such
a strong Bishop so you may have to sack
it back to be honest here that's a
really rock solid Bishop I like how you
said Rock there like on D4 I mean you
can never move it and like how what do I
do now yeah I have the exchange but this
is tough I mean wow Magnus is definitely
showing some class here I mean yes okay
you got your exchange but look at this
bishop I mean my knight I know you I
don't have any weaknesses anymore maybe
A4 I mean even if you win that it's
still not as clear yeah this is the
human touch over analysis has engines
computers because I think computers
probably didn't have this on the first
two or three options but I just love it
for white it's so easy to play now you
just bring a rook across to A1 you throw
this white a pawn up the board you trade
off pawns nothing to worry about ready
for white and uh the evaluation bar is
still in the middle showing that yeah
Magnus solid I think that's the best
case scenario from the position he had
earlier and I think he can't recognizes
it the way he's been looking at this
position is like oh I should have
something and you see it on his face
right now as soon as I see him
copying each other imitation is the most
sincere form of flattery so thank you
for that but I I think that a car's look
it's like I should be better right I
have a rook for just a night and one
Pawn but A4 was a wonderful choice that
Rook on H1 magnus's lone Rook it's not
doing anything it's not participating in
the game but he may swing it to the
other side of the board push that pawn
to A5 and say my Rook is going to get
active whether you like it or not I'm
going to trade off some material so if
you want to sacrifice and exchange back
by Rook takes D4 have fun with that
there's not enough material remaining
I'm not going to lose this game he also
got to pass Pawn now look at the eval
bar like ahaha got you don't think
that's what you get right and the white
Rook gets active nonetheless Suddenly
It's white maybe with the advantage the
White Knight very stable the black
Bishop not stable at all and Nakamura
brings his Rook across Maybe uh just
having lost a turn there full Tempo he
could have played this move on the last
go and if he does offer this Rook trade
of course Magnus will say no the white
Bishop White Knight only hold their own
uh if there's a white Rook on the board
and Magnus will avoid that trade for
sure as Robert mentions trying to get
his own Rook active next move and that's
just a general tip if you're playing
with minor pieces they're always much
stronger if you have a rook uh in
combination
with them and uh looking good for white
I've got to say or at least looking
stable enough it's still not better but
uh that's actually a great point that
you just made David that in these kind
of positions Magnus has to avoid The
Rook trade to keep the bishop and the
Knight the minor pieces hold their own
against the exchange that Magnus is
currently down he wants to get that a
pawn rolling he wants to try and create
weaknesses in Black's Camp is that is
that a threat that Hikaru can stop right
now or is hikar going to create his own
counter player well I think that if the
queen side pawns get traded off the
board the game's Amelia draw so that is
what Magnus aim for if the Rooks come
off now the reason why white will lose
is because of the presence of the queen
side pawns the bishop and the Knight
they're far to the side they won't be
able to defend those pawns on the queen
side so if the and a pawns are off then
you could trade Rook you still make a
draw because there's nothing black can
do to kick your minor Pieces away yeah
and I heard this great saying I think it
was by Jesse cry Jesse cray and uh he
was saying it's like uh ice cream
flavors you want one of everything when
you're the exchange down here you want a
rook you want a bishop you want a knight
because they actually combine uh really
well together you make a Sunday so make
us something exactly there you can make
a tasty Sunday but uh yeah without one
of those flavors it becomes a much more
bland position much more one-dimensional
and it's not to everyone's taste so yeah
I think here actually believe it or not
the only plan that we see that's here
for black here David is maybe like this
is a long shot because I mean his pieces
are so well placed Magnus is that the
plan I mean even if time is getting even
more even now too is a rook C1 right
he's gonna avoid the tree bring the
other rule he didn't play it but my goal
here is to play King 7 and go G5 then
after I'm poissons play G5 again get rid
of the Knight and get my Rook to C2 and
the other one to G1 wow this is the um
it's a long-term plan but if I can get
this then I can win the G2 Pawn but it
takes a while to do this yeah instead I
like this James at least from a point of
view of going for the win Hikaru choose
is the most solid option uh we see this
position in front of us there's been a
trade of one set of Pawns on that side
on the queen side and white should be
relatively safe feels like Nakamura he's
just set up a barrier blacks Rook on the
seventh rank Black's Bishop make sure
that the white Rook will never get
active and wow indeed he is retreating I
think he's just saying okay I'm gonna
play for the draw he offering a draw wow
yeah he did offer a draw and I don't
know what if Magus hasn't seen it but he
should probably accept yeah I I think
Magnus knows he's kind of considering it
he gave that look but then Hikaru
shaking his head wow Hikaru open
exchanges offered a draw what would we
do here in the studio would we say yes
if we were Magnus or no oh yeah
about to push this boy I can't move
nothing he said yes oh congratulations
he said yes
he made him an offer he couldn't refuse
wow
that means we are going to be heading
into an Armageddon hey girl he still
can't believe Magnus accepted the draw
I'm not sure what's going on there but
I'm loving what I'm watching on the
camera he's analyzing for sure he's
looking where he could have done better
I mean he has a wooden Shield I mean he
has a wooden shield and a pond and I
mean you know it's a wooden Shield
wow quite a complex
complicated game that was by these two
players with Nakamura up in exchange but
Magnus Carlsen with the compensation
David break it down for us yeah and I
guess some of the viewers at home might
be wondering why the game ended
prematurely there why the players agreed
to a draw and this was the final
position Black's Rook has just retreated
to the eighth rank to the ca square and
essentially Nakamura is saying I'm
defending everything and indeed this
black Bishop holds the queen Side Pawn
nothing to worry about on that flank and
these two black Rooks hold any
infiltration squares for White's pieces
meanwhile on the inverse side on the
flip side for uh black here you can't
break through either this white knight
guards some very important pawns the
only pawns on light squares the only two
potential weaknesses nothing to be done
there for black and this Rock Solid
Bishop the best Bishop you'll ever see
defended by a Pawn on a beautiful
Outpost and it appears at both sides of
the board essentially neither side can
make progress without worsening their
own chances without taking massive risks
so the status quo the status quo is
contained and the draw was agreed
wow Hikaru offers a drop Magnus accepts
it and with that we are heading into an
Armageddon after two very exciting draws
after
the stretch break we will be back with a
breakdown on the strengths and
weaknesses of these two players
[Music]
foreign
it's okay
[Music]
the message I really want to send to
people is that
you know man
the adults have to do better you know to
create a better culture because there
were so many accounts that I I've heard
that were mentioned in the article where
people's
very young at the time would say like
well you know I everybody else around me
acted like it was normal so I didn't say
anything I didn't do anything it just
was very normalized and yeah that just
needs to stop and we need to step up and
make sure that our game is like safe and
and fun for everyone
foreign
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
Magnus Carlsen the world number one
multiple-time world champion and winner
of the previous two editions of the
Champions chess tour Magnus has played
every opening under the sun he even has
a variation of the Sicilian named after
him so after E4 C5 Magnus started
playing Knight C3 a few years ago with
the idea that he could open the center
immediately by playing D4 actually going
against conventional chess wisdom of
developing the White Queen very early
but the whole idea here is that after
the queen gets kicked away she's happy
to step back and for example if black
continues to develop normally white just
creates a fiancato gets the bishop to a
nice diagonal and later castles on the
queen side actually a very aggressive
opening not technically part of magnus's
Style magnus's real recipe for success
is that he adopts his strategy according
to the opponent he's able to do anything
with a very Universal style and if you
get him in the end game there's no
chance he's perhaps the best end game
player of all time and you can go and
check out some of his ideas some of the
Source on the end game in his chessboard
courses
two of the very best players in the
world facing each other and it has gone
down to the while as we will be seeing
the Armageddon we love to watch the
fights and battles between these two
players Magnus Carlson and Hikaru
Nakamura Robert what makes Magnus so
strong in these formats it's a great
question Magnus Carlson he plays
Everything Under the Sun he's afraid of
nothing and no one including when he
played in the Olympiad against Mickey
Adams David's compatriot and good friend
in that game he played what's known as
the Norwegian rat defense where white
plays E4 and after the move D6 he plays
D4 and he plays his G6 Knight C3 Knight
F6 and he brings his Knight over to H5
it is I think I messed up the Mover
honestly it's such a weird rare line
David you got me covered but Magnus will
play anything under the sun wow bro with
all these offbeat openings that Magnus
keeps playing how difficult is it for
his opponents to prepare against him
it's nearly impossible but the same is
true for a car right James absolutely of
course hikaro being an absolute Beast
strong tactical Wizardry right of course
one of my favorites of course I've
followed a lot of his games especially
when King's Indian if we bring up this
one right here this is actually against
gel fan right playing with the black
pieces where he left his Queen hanging
for like four moves right if you see it
here of course Bishop H3 in this
position right I mean if David got me
here as a after Queen after uh his Queen
was attacked he played Bishop to H3
which was the name this position
Bishop H3 Ryan Bishop H3 Queen hanging
right okay right then we have the next
move what happened here Bishop F1 yeah
one right okay then after Bishop
everyone what did he played David queen
23. look this game up look this game up
this is against girlfriend this is the
type of chest that I like and this is
why I'm a big fan of Hikaru as well
because he plays this kind of Chess this
is from a king's Indian for all you
Kings fans out there what happened after
this name uh White ended up playing on
and resigning a few moves later but I
guess the main idea James Fisher takes
Queen yep and boom Checkmate absolutely
beautiful it's disgusting here right of
course the work on G7 defends the bishop
on G2 here and actually in a few more
moves he was able to take the Knight on
C3 and he ended up winning this game
very cleanly but the queen was hanging
for like three or four moves very
aggressive tactical player sees things
that a lot of us just you know wish we
could see and you can't see these things
obviously if you do a lot of calculation
over everything and also follow hikaru's
games as well
Angus so much Robert and James Magnus
Carlsen with his worried opening
repertoire making him one of the most
difficult players to prepare against as
Robert mentioned and of course the super
aggro style of Hikaru Nakamura as James
just showcased makes him such a beast of
course both these players are extremely
Universal can't handle any types of any
type of positions but right now they
have to handle the Armageddon some Mind
Games we're expecting in the bid the
player who bids the lower time wins the
Armageddon bid gets to choose the color
usually it's black because black gets
result odds which means that if it's a
draw black wins the match white has to
win the Armageddon on demand the
opponent starts with 15 minutes no
increment wow that's always a lot of fun
now guys in the air things Masters we
saw so much drama with the Armageddon
bits what are we expecting how low is
too low I don't want to go first David
you save me I think anything under eight
minutes is too low we've seen it in the
past 11 aronian made it work against
ultimate but it came down to one or two
seconds Magnus bid under eight minutes
once and he was punished on the first
day of this tournament so I think we'll
see maybe eight nine minutes
minimum it should be more than that I
don't think they can take risks yeah
Magnus bids 8 and wins that means Hikaru
starts with 15 that just feels like too
much of a Time Advantage for Hikaru yeah
it's a tricky situation because a lot of
time but he also gets the white pieces
but then it's a draw and draw wins and
also a win-wins with black like how much
time do you have I mean really it's like
a mess right now and of course but
Magnus always usually outbids everybody
I don't know how he does it so I can't
wait to see the bit here to see if he
even wins this bid at all well you
called it
reveal the
nine minute 27 seconds loses the mid to
Hikaru Nakamura who've been nine minutes
17 seconds it is Advantage Hikaru he
takes the black pieces but starts with 9
minutes 17 seconds Robert what do you
make of this winning bid it is Adventure
car it has been Advantage car over the
chess board so I'm not surprised that he
won the psychological battle as well but
I don't think Magnus will be too unhappy
because he gets a huge head start on the
clock yeah how much of a mental win is
this for Hikaru it will be huge we saw
two months ago in the air things Masters
Magnus outbid Hikaru by one second and
Magnus went on to take that Armageddon
so uh now okay it's a 10 second
difference but clearly uh Hikaru getting
exactly what he wanted
will start with the black pieces and he
does Hikaru with the black pieces
and he will have nine minutes how much
did he weigh 10 seconds No 17. 9 minute
and 17 seconds Magnus Carlsen starts
with 15 minutes the English opening
we've seen Magnus do this before today
seen it before and it worked extremely
well against Levon aronian and uh will
lightning strike twice that's the
question nine minutes against Magnus
Carlson most of us wouldn't be able to
handle it but uh here we go Nakamura
clearly has done his preparation he
would have been watching that much
earlier today that Magnus had and uh
okay Magnus just fearing Kettering black
is the first to Castle black can
actually wreck the white porn structure
right now I'm surprised by this Choice
uh Robert James what do you think of
this opening you know I like it for
Magnus and Hikaru is starting to think
here because any sort of imbalance is
good for the side that needs to win the
game if you take on C3 with that Bishop
the pawn structure is ruined double
isolated pawns we keep talking about how
we don't like those but we love
ourselves a good Bishop pair so here's
the big moment will Hikaru take on C3
James yeah I don't think he will and the
reason being the bishop pair is very
nice I also do not want to give him that
imbalance with me having his big time
difference too as well unless you know
if I know the theory which it looks like
he doesn't hear he's now thinking now so
of course they may be a little bit out
of theory here I need to make something
happen but I don't need to figure out
what I want to do with this bishop
because if I it's kind of a clumsy
Bishop too as well it could be hit by
many things I'm also moving it a second
or third time I may need to make a move
like a okay but H6 but maybe he's going
to tuck the bishop on f8 if it's
attacked because we need to move it
somewhere he couldn't wreck the
structure but he doesn't know exactly
what he's doing afterwards right and
we're going to get rid of the Bishops
here oh we what is this Knight D5 let's
get spicy already yeah wow Magnus saying
okay we can trade all the knights off
the board but the structure change might
favor white wow okay when you need to
win this is uh counterintuitive somewhat
allowing all these trades but he's
asking big questions Nakamura has spent
a bit of time so far big difference in
the clock and that's what surprises me
he has already spent about a minute and
a half he goes into a think tank and
this trade yes it favors now to remember
if this game ends in a draw Hikaru
actually wins the match you would think
it's simple go for the nitrate but it
changes the structure and asymmetrical
Pawn structure and you've got to
evaluate where that really leads or will
Magnus recapture with the bishop if he
trades all the knights it just leads to
an event is for white and this is
looking like it's happening here I don't
like this for a car it's magnus's style
of position we have a semi-open C file
for the white Rooks to go after the
black pods black has not finished
development either I do not like this
one bit for a car and he's way down on
the clock he's spending so much time
already yeah I've seen Magnus actually
have this exact porn structure several
times including you mentioned him
earlier Michael Adams in the London
chess classic a few years ago Magnus had
this exact structure also with the
Bishops also with that very far Advanced
Central Pawn and he just destroyed Adams
there uh just completely outplayed him
extra space for white whites Rooks have
access to the open C file which is going
to be essential later on Magnus first
though he's got a guard against some
attacks against his Central Pawn
unexpecting that dark squared Bishop to
just come out and I think Advantage
white on both board and clock
yeah that's tough that's tough here and
definitely I'm one move away from
completing development really in a way
which he does but should be three my
works are now connected and I can bring
the a rook to the C file here just try
to play this position is as deep as I
can C6 might be a thing here
um after Rook to C1 if he even plays
that there's a bishop D4 here hey this
is definitely magnus's grind type
position it's just boring like but I
have space which is very important space
is definitely some type of Advantage I
can do things with space I really wanted
to have the bishop on the long diagonal
but you know it's not really feasible
especially if I can play F6 or even
Bishop E5 to trade more pieces off so
you want to keep a few pieces on he
plays Rook D1 maybe a potential D6 later
on if possible B6 for Bishop B7 okay
yeah I guess that black light Square
Bishop needed to breathe you don't need
it to get out somehow and he's found a
way to do that there is a threat on the
board Black's dot Square Bishop wants to
slide to C5 hitting the White Queen
hitting the white Bishop uh on E3 as
well so Magnus needs to move his Queen
and he needs to move it now yeah and
Magnus just deciding which is a good
Square to move to the queen to Meanwhile
Hikaru developing his own light Squad
Bishop it could step up to B7 it could
step up to A6 but it is going to be
about the time scramble it is going to
be about trying to bring Magnus down to
level the clock for Hikaru but currently
Magnus keeps a huge time advantage on
the clock but he's he's gone into a bit
of a think right now what square has
come to your mind Queen G4 Queen D Queen
T2 yeah he just Retreats the queen I
think it's a good decision but to me
this is a tale of two halves not first
half second half like we think in sports
but here it's about the halves of the
board we look at the left side of the
board the Queen side black has four
pawns to whites three but unfortunately
for black those pawns are not so mobile
and that is going to be a problem for a
car to do with because if that Bishop
safely moves away from E3 for white
watch out that Palm will go up to E4
afterwards maybe F4 to follow and then
the pawns are rolling so I think that
White's pawns are just better place and
a car will have to work out for him yeah
he does and okay he's playing on the
side he's strongest makes a lot of sense
he pushes this Pawn forward he's saying
okay these two will never Advance at
least maybe this bishop will try to make
Robert's plan uh slightly less feasible
by putting some pressure on this
backward E Pawn but Magnus is saying
okay look at my Rooks there's so much
more uh efficient than yours right now
this is the big Target in the position
and watch out for Magnus as well at the
right moment trying to trade off these
Bishops just to highlight the weakness
of this backward Pawn still early days
of course but lots of Maneuvers here and
maneuvering positions actually cost
players more time on the clock so in
terms of the Armageddon great strategy
for Magnus this one is not going to
fizzle out anytime soon we won't see
Queen trades anytime soon either so how
is Hikaru going to manage with six
minutes no increment and is that
magnus's strategy just keep the pieces
on the board just keep making moves even
if they don't have direct threats he
just wants to bring Hikaru down on the
clock flag him you remember the advice
we gave our temir be Shameless Magnus is
no problem with that he will flag a car
if the opportunity presents itself and
right now he has nearly doubled the time
we think his position is better here so
I think James will agree with me over
here a Magnus he knows how to play a
bullet game or two absolutely 100 knows
how to play bullet in the end with the
best of them I'm even playing Hikaru all
the time in these matches too as well I
mean people always like hey these guys
should play akaro and Magnus should play
mini games in bullet people want this to
happen and Bishop f4 on the board what
trades offered and that's exactly what
we're talking about that Magnus needs to
keep more pieces on the board is this a
surprising move definitely yeah there's
a trap involved in this move if black
gets greedy here Hikaru is calculating
it he will have to burn some time here
but if you get greedy and grab upon this
backfires instantly your queen is hit
immediately and skewered yeah Queen
takes Queen there's an intermediate
check the vision so fish and shuck as
they say in German uh in between check
and when the king moves the queen drops
white has won a rook so Hikaru spots
that of course he moves his bishop and
now Magnus will be thinking firstly he
can step is Pawn Ford free of charge you
can start advancing on the side you're
stronger we talked about those two
halves of the board secondly there might
be sacrifices on this square at the
right moment and uh yeah I would be
worried for Hikaru if white can get away
with that safely first of all the porn
star advancing the Avalanche begins and
uh okay after a trade look how backward
this Pawn is on C7 Eternal witness to
Black that's ugly
wow this looks like bad news and Magnus
they're hinting or doubling up on the
sea lion targeting the weakness that
David you just pointed out is this
position more dangerous than it looks
for Hikaru Robert hikar wouldn't want
this position a classical game against
Magnus Carlsen you give them both an
hour I still think that white wins this
position a large percentage of the time
because the position for black you're
just shuffling back and forth white can
make progress and speaking of progress
throw the H1 up the board there could be
an attack because black is saddled with
this weakness C7 every move that's being
played is actually growing the advantage
for Magnus yeah it's like the board is
cut in half you mentioned those two
halves white is totally in control on
both flanks now and uh black his army
will be stretched later on they will be
overwhelmed most likely because Black's
pieces will be tied down to that weak C7
Pawn the backward point we highlighted
and Magnus will switch his attention to
the other flank too I know where it's
coming G4 I was like can I play G4 here
anytime I can put a Pawn on G4 we're
going for right so G4 Rook G3 G5 is
coming you have The Rook living can
shift to both sides of the board I mean
white is definitely in control in this
game yeah beautiful decision it's the
tale of two fronts if you attack on both
sides the opponent cannot uh well will
not have a reply and also six extra
minutes that has grown since the start
of this game the time Advantage Nakamura
wincing not enjoying his last move but
he needed to put pawns on dark squares
he has no Dart score Bishop he needs
some control
when you put the pawns on dark squares
your light squares become weaker if that
Bishop on G2 if you could pick it up and
put on the Square F5 I think black would
be toast but unfortunately that Bishop
is behind its own wall of pawns for the
moment at some point soon we may see
that Bishop head to H3 push that pawn to
G5 and I know James likes to say we live
because that Bishop May kill Black's
Chances with the Checkmate absolutely
you want to play something like Bishop
B7 but you can't even play that because
it connect it breaks the connection of
uh the pawn on C7 he plays G5 anyway
break it up open up shop Big Fellas wow
open up he's really going for it not
holding back at all H4 G4 G5 what
momentum and it looks like the Rooks are
ready to get into the attack as well
every single piece perfectly placed for
this
great for white however Hikaru hits
Magnus with a threat uh the White Queen
there needed to step back that was an
important Tempo Gainer and now black has
gone up a pawn temporarily but watch out
for this white Bishop it's coming James
what you can play that you can take on
C7 now you can get away with it wow
White's Rook can just grab that backward
Pawn that we've been talking about this
looks fantastic does it does a David yep
and after this Rook trade we're going to
be left with a position still Level
material but Black's King's so open
white Rook is coming into the seventh
rank this looks like a massacre it
should end in a chat meeting attack you
know what move I like here because white
could give a check but the black king
will escape back I would put them in
Queen H7 take away the Escape score that
just feels like a speed chess move
because now hit car is a figure after
the queen goes up to H7 with Rook C7
check coming next where is your king
going to it's going to be a quick
Checkmate so I think this is a very
nasty move to face when you have a few
minutes in your clock really instructive
you find that move by looking at your
opponent's replies your opponent's plans
and their hopes after root check as
Robert says actually the king is pretty
safe temporarily on G8 so cut that one
out so Magnus is paused he's not playing
the most natural move in the position
this Rook check therefore he might find
the even stronger Queen H7 taking away
taking control of the Escape square that
might be a killer Nakamura with four
minutes on his clock where he will
struggle to find a defense to that move
Queen H7 it's a strong move wow Hikaru
was thinking about Queen at seven as
well he definitely has it on his radar
he's trying to think what happens if
Magnus finds this move it is a big
moment in this Armageddon game if Magnus
goes Queen at seven big trouble for
Hikaru on the clock four and a half
minutes is he going to do it or will he
give a check with the queen or The Rook
immediately hates the fact that Magnus
found this move yeah because now what
does black do because you want to block
a check on the seventh rank but you
can't give the eighth rank either in
most end games will be winning for white
let's talk about Pawn structure for a
second Black's Pawn structure is broken
so most end games will result in a
pretty easy advantage and maybe a win
for white so I'm not liking to look this
for a car especially now as he's about
to dip under four minutes yeah you need
an hour on your clock to defend this one
but uh Hikaru doesn't have that luxury
okay he brings his Rook across really
nice defense he's actually trying to
slide his King back the other way and uh
the black rook and the black queen are
actually lined up so watch out for a
counter attack against the white king
later queen of Rook positions when it's
just major heavy pieces on the board
it's all about to say King safety
Black's King not safe but the white king
might have some questions too this boy
got some of the best defense I've ever
seen Rick f8 is nasty because after
check King E8 now I'm hitting F2 and the
draw is all I need big fellow so if you
make a mistake and I take on F2 I at
least have a draw there you might even
be losing in some cases so wow I mean
what a defensive move there after Rook
check came to E8 and now H2 is hanging I
was also thinking if I could play E5
here oh E5 is that it dislodges the
queen right I started on the board upon
E5 is nice I mean if Queen takes then
you might be in some trouble here yeah
engine automatically goes up and maybe
like a queen something H5
Queen C2 maybe nc2 is nasty James
because I have to defend and yeah and
you've got no C6 and we'll check yeah
absolutely
I am a Jedi sometimes I forget that
sometimes I forget but it is uh that's
nice but let's go back to pawn takes
after E5 what happens on Pawn takes yeah
and this is the problem I had same idea
maybe just Rook C7 check maybe 66 first
oh yeah you're right you're right same
idea but the point the queen comes back
to C2 so James you're mixing offensive
defense and that's nasty I appreciate
that Jedi I appreciate that yeah Big Rob
I'm trying to get like you okay so yeah
that's nice let's see what happens one
thing I want to point out yesterday
Hikaru blundered mating one on the f8
Square now he's learned from that last
day it was Rook f8 now he finds a
defense Rook f8 I was just looking that
was the only move pretty much to stay in
this game for hikarum knuckleberry so
he's learned from yesterday but uh will
Magnus find a breakthrough now the more
I look at it James the more I like that
move I think Magnus needs to go for
something like that before it's too late
otherwise the advantage might fizzle out
and disappear he's calculating right now
but in just 30 seconds finds the best
move in the position for black bringing
that Rook not just defending his King
but also putting pressure on magnus's
King on G1 it's not an easy idea to find
what James has mentioned to retreat the
queen all the way back to that C2 Square
once the e-pawn advances will Magnus be
able to find this he's gone into a think
tank he is looking for the blow in this
position
do you think he's going to go for this
will he sacrifice the epon I don't know
I didn't see it coming until James
mentioned it so while I'm trying to wrap
my head around this I want a quick shout
out to Maxima Sherlock he takes down
Anish Gary makes it to the Grand Final
in division two so mvl the Frenchman
with three names he's doing quite well
shout out to over 60 000 of you watching
this broadcast we appreciate you too
60k hey everyone what's good we here you
know what up yeah I think the world just
loves to see Magnus and Hikaru battle it
out and this is why we love it both
players bringing on the best attack and
the best defense I see the eval bar it
says that black is still fine well you
don't have E5 just yet because the F2
Pawn is hanging counter-attack black has
a threat that's why a move order was so
important James is kind of fleeting
opportunity pushing that white Pawn
forward it's not available anymore let's
just show that uh Queen takes Pawn is a
killer blue uh if black gets time for it
Queen takes Pawn that's why Rook f8 was
such a nice defense for uh Hikaru now
how does let's deal with this you have
to take your time out you don't really
want to have to retreat the White Queen
to a passive Square what would she be
doing here I don't think she's doing
much and what else you simply have to do
something do you bring your Rook back
but that feels wrong he's checked and
traded off the Rooks and uh we're in a
queen end game this is the current
position the worst is over no past pawns
for white first is over man this might
be a drop yeah and it's equal Bond and
if it's a draw that means a girl
actually takes a match he knocks out
Magnus Carlton to go into the Grand
Final Hikaru Magnus they're missing a
big opportunity but Hikaru is going to
have to defend this till the very end
it's going to be very difficult because
of the pawn structure look at Black's
pawns they're loose no matter where your
head turns to and there's a pawn hanging
black attack White's Pawn on B2 but that
won't be a good idea because white will
deliver a check and win this D6 pawn and
in this kind of end game it's often
about the quality of the pawns and if
white can win a pass Pawn there if we
just show this one Queen B2 check take
on D6 with check and the important point
is the D5 Pawn will run to the other
side we'll see a second Queen appear
white will win this game so hikara sees
this and now he's deep in the think tank
he really doesn't have that much time
Magnus actually can flag a car over here
three minutes is not that much compared
to your opponent's five this is tough
this actually is tough I mean queening
games are the hardest ones and go
through you open up your Denver Rescue
page 687 right when you get there and
it's going to tell you about the queen
in games that are very hard like this
one but yeah Queenie 5000 but like it's
it's definitely difficult very hard to
defend this actually yeah centralization
with the queen makes sense when in doubt
centralize your queen uh the one thing I
know about Queen end games is that
nobody knows anything about good night
games they're that difficult you just
have to guess at some point you have so
many options Black's Queen had five or
six viable squares why not choose the
center just make that quick decision and
Magnus I don't think there's anyone as
good in Queen and games as Magnus in
history so if anyone can win it it
should be him objectively though it
feels like black should be safe enough
because the white king isn't exactly
protected either we could definitely see
a Perpetual check later if the black
queen is able to start harassing the
enemy King so Hikaru if he's uh able
should be able to hold this but uh three
minutes I really fear for him on the
clock Magnus needs to speed up just
bring that White Queen back somewhere to
safety and just keep the tension keep
asking those questions Black's King not
finding anywhere any safe squares
anytime soon it's the problem is the
safe squares I might actually find
safety if I can by actually moving the
king forward as you saw with the Fabi
game Hikaru when the king went all the
way up to G4 something similar like that
because if I can get my king to maybe F4
and say yes so that's not gonna be
allowed now so we just King Jesus I can
spend a long time on that move though
over a minute and uh with only a few
minutes left with Armageddon format that
it could be vital later the black king
advances White's pawns now Under Fire on
the queen side Black's Queen may be
threatening to go and capture them in
the next move or two
yeah just needs to defend for a move hey
Carl brings the king into the game
playing the role of a key Defender for
the king side pawns so playing with
whatever is left makes a lot of sense
meanwhile White's King isn't that active
it looks like magnus's hopes up purely
on the clock right now and of course
thinking can I take this Pawn on B2
men's brings his King up I thought he
was going to push the pawn that was
under attack to save it and of course
look at it he wants to snack on it and I
feel like what the proper magnets right
now is even if he starts throwing this
game his Advantage out the window he
needs to start making moves more quickly
Hikaru would punish Magnus if the colors
reverse on the clock Magnus needs to do
the same yeah Magnus he's a great speed
player of course but his Mouse skills I
don't know if they match hikaru's and uh
okay still extra minute on the clock he
does fix the structure on the queen side
and the black king runs in that
direction actually if the Queens
disappear Magnus has great winning
chances right now can he force that in a
favorable situation advancing leading
from the front the white king I was not
expecting that move yeah King F3
definitely is a nice move because I'm
like zugged out meaning Zog zwang like
what do I do as black I just have to
shuffle back and forth
and G6 a huge blunder what did Hikaru
Miss say what is the winning move it
might be it might have been it's not six
it might have been Queen E6 what what's
the winner and King G4 oh my goodness
wow forcing the Queens off was winning
James is right right just a couple of
moves ago this was not obvious at all
for a human as a lot of different rescue
there you know pawning games right Queen
E6 takes and then King G4 King F6 and I
think he zugged out F3 let's quickly
show that James Queen Swap and as you
mentioned it is zuk Swang this position
black needs to defend his pawns and uh
here white can just wait okay for
example Black's King can even hit this
one and you have another waiting move
you just push this button yeah GG you
win wow sick and second event in row
where Hikaru is fortunate because
against Wesley so in the air things
Masters this was exactly what was
happening in a queen end game a queen
trade could have led to a win for Wesley
but I think this is not over for Hikaru
magazine to keep the game going look at
the clocks Magnus is up nearly 40
seconds and the defensive task just
because the King has run to the queen
side it's not over for Hikaru yeah this
one he's gonna have to defend backs to
the wall for the rest of this game at
least another 50 moves and he's gonna
have to keep Pace on the clock look at
the two kings they're running to safety
we said there's never gonna be safety
for them they're hiding from any
potential checks outside David the clock
it's getting Level there so it will come
down to some dirty flagging by both of
them if the Queens get traded it is
Advantage Magnus simply because of
hikaru's horrible Pawn structure working
Pawn ending but till the Queens are
alive Hikaru it's game on he just needs
a draw yeah just needs a draw and wow 10
seconds in it now magnus's camera also
froze for a second this is very relevant
is his internet connection able to hold
her
another big king move I mean he is
playing unexpected King who's first at
three now to B3 and hikar gives up D6
you want steak E4 um is there an actual
check does he pick up the E4 doesn't
start checking check start checking that
white king he goes B3 there's no
Perpetual yet he goes He zigzag the A3
and b3f while Hikaru now tanking for 20
seconds he needs to move I don't think
you can get away with just grabbing that
white Pawn in the center white would
then be the one giving the checks
gaining time on the clock you need to
check and just hope for the best you
need to move on the clock he's done a
one minute 15 seconds this is not good
unless he has a draw by force he is
going to be in trouble being flagged he
has to check it's a bullet game now
looking at three only move correct
B3 B3 tracks but Queen C3 there's Queen
C6 I don't know what happened to the
queen trade there what about centralized
and then third mate right and then check
everywhere else yeah he has a check but
then I run A6 he's got to work it out
with less than a minute on his clock can
he afford a queen trade can he threaten
Checkmate trap that white king somehow
on the edge of the board he needs to
find an accurate move if he makes a slip
now Hikaru he's losing Queen B1 I think
though there's always Queen C6 back to
see there she goes here I think Magnus
anyway Queen C6 check and bring his
Queen back to defense as long as you
don't allow a Perpetual check he can
flag Hikaru yeah just give a couple of
checks first a couple of quick checks
game time on the clock and then Retreat
that White Queen yes there's no
increment though well he does give a
check if he comes back there is a check
on A1 where do you retreat with your
queen back to C1 to the first rank I
know you're giving up a pawn F2 you
maybe find yourself in a losing position
at some point but you need to beat him
on the clock he only has 45 seconds yeah
45 seconds just check make your opponent
react that's how you kind of gain time
especially considering uh your
opponent's lower but Magnus is too slow
again not switching to that Armageddon
mindset you've got to be nasty you've
got to be mean here just flag that's
right and that's yeah he's definitely
when the time gets closer Hikaru does
get a Little Bit Stronger here yep there
it is he push and immediately made a
move here oh wow but that move the Eva
bar went up so why can we well Queen E1
you have the A1 Square covered you
protect your Pawn you may just start
throwing that pass one of the body
places
from advancing or is this just game over
I think that the blocking with his Queen
but then he's no more checks yeah and
then the black queen will be purely
passive it's going to be one-way traffic
the White Queen is going to activate
herself now and you can play Forever
this position Magnus but five six
seconds in it wow it's all about the
clock now it's a winning position for
white we think oh it makes a better
position but is it enough on the clock I
don't think he's made a mistake but he
is up a few seconds this is going to
come down to the wire everybody
what what I mean you can't trade Queens
the black key would be too close
any safe Square for black Perpetual
coming oh my god oh quitty two checks we
have a counter check if black checks in
the second race he's checking diagonals
wow can be one
gotta move oh no checks
oh and what's happened there what
happened we see a reaction Magnus
oh no oh my god did he pre-move
he now slipped oh and hey Carlos
celebrating
Magnus must slept blundering into that
Queen
what an
Endura ticks
this match
unbelievable what a finish we didn't
expect that
we thought it might be on decided on the
board decided on the clock but not with
a mouth slip and uh Magnus yeah me
Furious Furious Justice harsh chess is
hard bro resilient defense from the
color I mean this guy he just does not
lose what a beast I mean just impossible
to beat you're up on the clock you gotta
play it out till the end what a player
Hikaru Nakamura in the Armageddon you've
got to use all your chances and that's
what he did he certainly did I mean to
win that game with mere seconds on your
clock he had a bunch of checks at his
disposal Magnus is trying to avoid a
draw by force he must have been lost his
Queen but Hikaru was putting up
tenacious defense the whole way through
yeah we're just in shock right now wow
what happened there David at the very
end we have to show in slow motion those
uh final moves both sides had mere
seconds left white still has an extra
Pawn objectively though black is active
enough to hold the draw this position
white king hiding from checks no way for
the black queen to continue harassing uh
that white king now and it's actually
with white to play a win if you step
forward this is a discover check the
pawn can step forward attacking the
enemy King and uh here Hikaru found a
really clever defense moved his King
across Magnus decided okay the pawn is
dropping anyway I'm gonna throw it out
the way this is a discover check the
king takes the pawn and the move Magnus
wanted to play was Queen takes this Pawn
if he takes this Pawn he's actually a
pawn up the game goes on it should be a
draw but uh I think he would have won on
time instead however he did drop the
queen on its Journey to the B6 Square on
F6 the worst possible Mouse slip of
course losing the queen after King takes
Queen and
that was how this final was decided
Hikaru moves on actually any other queen
move where you're not dropping it on the
spot you win and that was the pain on a
Magnus Carlsen after that Mouse slip
giving the game giving the match and
Magnus Carlsen is out of the tournament
and Hikaru what a fighter what a beast
he takes this Armageddon he kept up his
resourcefulness he did not give it give
up in the end many would have and it
paid off wow
what a match
man that's crazy the defense was serious
oh just unbelievable stuff and this was
our score line we saw two epic fights in
the rapid ending in Jaws and a
nail-biting Armageddon which was which
just had us on the edge of our Scene It
could have gone either way and in the
end the mouse slip cause caused Magnus
Carlsen the match which means that
Hikaru Nakamura will be moving on to the
Grand Final against Fabiano caruana and
we are being joined by the winner Hikaru
congratulations
thanks yeah I was a wild Nash but I came
out on top
it really was your resistance your
resilience and resourcefulness was that
the key to today's match victory
yeah I mean this match of course uh I
mean it really the first two games
weren't super exciting I mean the third
game obviously Armageddon was the one
that was really critical I mean I think
Marcus made a couple of mistakes
um I thought for example it's I mean a
mistake being a generic term but I
thought when Magnus played G5 it was not
a good decision practically because it
simplified the position I felt that at
that point I think I had maybe five and
a half minutes left and I thought that
he could have just played like Queen G3
and F4 just kept the pressure up and
kept the game going forever and he sort
of simplified a little bit too early
um obviously later I mean it still was
very very tricky
um but I I found I think a lot of very
very good moves or many moments when I
could have lost in the queen and pawn
end game I mean probably I had a couple
ways I could have drawn but I mean
without like two or three minutes on the
clock probably impossible so yeah it all
worked out
hey Cara it was amazing to see unfold
there and there's some great questions
from the chat about you and magazine
rivalry in some ways do you consider
this a kind of modern kaspara of karpov
dual
I mean uh I I guess you could say it
over the last like three or four years
since the pandemic began I mean I think
to be fair if you go prior to that um
what is a good example I think a good
example I'm trying to think of of like a
European analogy but I'll just use a
baseball one it's like comparing the New
York Yankees and the Boston Red Sox I
mean the Red Sox won a World Series in
1918 they didn't win again until I think
it was 2004. that's probably a better
comparison the Yankees want something
like like 15 or 16 World Series during
that time so I don't think um I don't
think you could say that in terms of the
early early days but you know the last
couple years I found a way to play play
well I mean I think the main thing is I
don't fall apart against Magnus in the
past I would have fallen apart very
quickly especially like this this third
game where when he played uh Queen H7 I
had Mrs Queen H7 idea all together
um and even if you you know I do
actually look at the cams I saw magnus's
reaction when I played Rook f8 he
realized that he had made a slight
mistake to allowing that um so there's
been a lot of back and forth the last
couple of years
um and I think yeah it's great for the
fans for sure well just on that note
hikar you're talking about some of the
psychology did you feel like you had the
upper hand when you outbid Magnus in
this Armageddon
no I mean I I think the thing is in this
event more than the first one like the
first one I was I think all of us were
trying to be like super precise in our
bid see just how low you can go
um and I kind of was like I'm just gonna
bid something I I didn't even really
think about it that much I was just like
make a bid who cares you got white you
got white you have six minutes just deal
with it um and so there wasn't I think
as much psychology going on um but it
was nice because I think if you go back
to the first event I think I was bidding
something like I did like seven was it
like 757 against Wesley or something
something completely ridiculous I mean I
got away with it but
um no I mean I I just I was happy to be
black having draws because of course in
chess most games do underdressing like
60 plus so that was an advantage but
still the opening I got was not good
Magnus complicated very early um but you
just keep trying to play moves and I
found a way
great Joby Carl congratulations uh
defensive wizard so uh we have a
question from the chat actually here is
what is your favorite thing to do after
a chess game or match
um my favorite
is do a recap for YouTube and make money
that's my favorite thing to do that's
beautiful
sorry congratulations on looking ahead
tomorrow you get chance for revenge
against Fabi what are your thoughts on
the match
yeah I mean I I don't know it's it's
gonna be tough I will say that like
coming off the high from today to um to
uh to have to play football on tomorrow
I mean to have to win one match and then
then win a second match um but you know
I I would say that if I look at this
event I felt that yesterday was the day
that I played The Worst by far and I
mean it's really unfortunate because
Fabiano also had a bad day I mean if
Fabian was playing well I wouldn't have
anything to complain about but he played
he didn't play his best either so I
think um you know probably come out
tomorrow try to play good chess and um I
I mean obviously have to win two matches
but uh you play and you see what happens
like I it could have gone either way it
was an awesome match and really fun to
watch so entertaining I have to ask you
know can I ask something briefly though
I just want to add one thing though
which I think is important like when I'm
talking about the moment when he played
G5 like the reason I say he's some fight
too early is because this queen and pod
end game if we reach his Queen upon end
game I think at the start of some like
three and a half minutes if I have like
two minutes there I lose that I would
say like 90 of the time but because he's
simplified too soon that extra like 90
seconds to extra like 100 seconds really
did make a huge huge difference like a
huge difference
um I do want to say that
right right wow
that was a very exciting magic it was an
awesome match to watch and I was gonna
ask you that in that final moment really
anything could have happened and we saw
the reaction on both you and Magnus and
maybe we can bring that up for you
because this was such a big moment and
you can see it when you fought so hard
and finally it goes your way what was
going on in your mind when that Queen F6
happened
I mean it was it was just nice to win
the match because again like this is the
thing that Magnus is better than anybody
else like there were men there were many
moments like around the time that he
played King B3 Queen D4 like when he
spent 30 seconds ago King B3 I played
Queen E4 I was sure it was a draw I
wasn't I mean I didn't see the four
straw but I was sure it was a draw and
then he found ways to keep it
complicated so it's like you're trying
to defend defend defend and um I mean he
can't win every match I mean I know he's
the greatest player of all time but he
can't win every match like somebody
can't just get lucky every single time
so uh it was it was just nice for a
change to have have something go my way
yeah it was amazing and what do you
think was the reason that everyone loves
watching a Magnus Hikaru matchup
I mean it's because I mean again like
it's because in the last couple of years
I've actually you know I've learned how
to play somewhat decently against Magnus
whereas for the previous 10 years I mean
I just lost every game it wasn't it
wasn't even close
um and I think when you combine that
with the fact that we're probably the
two most popular figures in chess right
now and if the matches are closed like
that's what you need in chess like you
don't want one-sided matches you don't
want things to be like be boring and
just wipe out it's like that's never
good for the fans and so I think um I
think when you have um when he was
playing the matches are always tense
always close so it's just very very good
for the game very good
I just have a quick question you talked
about your own growth playing Magnus
what can you say about Fabiano's growth
in quicker time patrols because he had
many critics in earlier stages of his
career but now he seems to do very well
in all of these rapid events
I mean I think that's just the nature of
Chess when you don't have classical
tournaments um all that frequently
anymore I mean like even somebody like
Fabiano who plays every everywhere over
the board event
um I mean I'm thinking he probably plays
maybe six or seven classical chess turns
a year and in the past it would have
been something like 10 11 12 and I think
when when you have to um when you have
to shift gears I mean Fabiano obviously
very serious player um he's taken Blitz
and Rapid much more seriously and I
think it shows in his results so again I
mean in a one-off tournament sometimes
he won't be he won't do great but but
overall everyone's so strong that it's
uh to me it's it's not that surprising I
mean it just really isn't surprising at
all and uh Hikaru final quick question
uh the T-shirt was that chosen
specifically for today
not really I mean I just I I figured why
not I mean because I
I there were moments when I I actually
did care too much like in that in that
first game in that second game against
Fabiano getting too excited too into it
and um now it wasn't really about today
it's just something to do something to
get people talking and um yeah it's what
it is yeah yeah that Armageddon
definitely got people talking fantastic
player Hikaru and fantastic resilience
as always thank you so much and
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
in the Grand Final
thank you so much you guys
too the Grand Final where he will be
playing against Fabiano caruana that
abrupt finish in the Armageddon I still
can't get all what just happened James
it's like karma in fact Nakamura got
made it in one rook f8 and then again
right back to him the the Kaiser or
whatever the chess guards they say right
came right back to him of course it
worked out for him so I mean hey we got
made it in one but the next day I beat
Carlson so I'm feeling good if I'm
Nakamura yeah that would actually
explain it a lot David I mean
yesterday's match against Fabi could
have gone either way as well and Hikaru
gets a chance for Revenge tomorrow
tomorrow what are you expecting yeah
most of us would have had our heads
hanging you know we would have been
cursing those chess Gods after a blunder
like yesterday but it shows the strength
of nakamura's character coming back from
that blunder to beat Magnuson tomorrow I
expect him to want revenge much more
than he showed actually in that
interview I think it will really drive
him and when he's in a final he's going
to try and win it so uh yeah it's gonna
be close Naco will uh have his task cut
out but I think he's the favorite
wow what action we had today and
tomorrow it does continue hikaru's got
to be feeling good and ready for that
Grand Final I'm sure your car is feeling
great but Fabiano's feeling rested and
he has not one life but two and look at
these results from Fabiano caruana since
the start of the air things Masters
knockout he was in division two look at
those dubs he bits this deep time ghost
then everyone else he beats is above
2600 including you yangi twice in the
air things Masters final then he comes
into the chessel Masters division one
after winning D2 he beats them lay
artemia Hikaru Nakamura he faces a car
again but he hasn't lost a match in
these four game Kos
yeah that's all dubs look at all the www
I just smelled up he is a dub walking
dub right okay uh Fabiano is all about
dubs and he's gonna try to get it done
tomorrow as well wow can I take it back
that nakamura's the favorite look at
these scores this is incredible this hot
streak from Fabi he's in grateful
yeah he is in a great farm and he's got
to keep that farm up tomorrow
Faith the Beast that is
what an Armageddon that was what a rapid
portion that was these two never never
failed to entertain us and give us the
best chess in the world there is also
amazing chess action in division two
let's bring up our graphic as we see
inadebeck Abdul sattro beat Maxim
three to oh that is destruction Robert
it was a clean sweep for the Uzbek
teenager Anish Guru Yu yengi moved on
but it actually kept going in division
two there are so many games to be played
here Anish he moved on past yugangi but
Maxine vashilograph revenge is on his
mind he gets to take on nerdybeck
abdusitarov in the D2 Grand Final that
should be fun one tomorrow as well there
is a lot of fun not just in division two
but division three as well wow I'm in
tabatabai taking down Alexi Serrano
David that was a big fight yeah big
fight but many congratulations to Amanda
butterby deserved it he went through he
won all of his matches and he takes
division three the title
amazing chess everywhere
I've been getting some amazing selfies
from our viewers we did say we will
reveal the winner I want to thank
everyone who sent in their selfies
watching the matches and showing us how
you are following the chasable Masters
okay I love that and that is our winner
of the day who has won an air things
device wow there's a lot going on in
that photograph there are you in airtime
you got you I love it that's right
that's why we're giving it to him
because I'm in it that's it that's the
main reason and this is the device that
we will be sending you the new wave plus
by air things so you will know how the
air quality is in your room so that you
can play your best chess
wow what action we had today and it has
been an amazing day of Chess a big shout
out to our chat for joining us on the
ride it's always a fun day when we've
got the best players in the world
playing the best tour we will be back
with the grand final tomorrow
[Music]
should we just do this for the whole
show
oh my goodness
well you better get him Black's Rook is
actually on third rack gonna come and
take a pawn with check attacking
multiple pieces
oh no my Paul and Eric rosenstyle I
really don't like the look this for
hikar on the board but also on the clock
that's fancy it's not just the soup the
game is over
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
relax
ing
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign